Die zwei Sprechstunden. Hier ist Chaosradio 187.
Das sagst du nur so.
Ich hab's aufgeschrieben.
Ja, du hast 187, ach nee nicht 188 aufgeschrieben.
Ich dachte, ja, in der Mail hast du mal was anderes behauptet. Damit du dich extra versprichst.
Hier ist Chaosradio 187, einen wunderschönen guten Abend mit mir im Studio.
Das sind der Erdgäste und der Joscha, es geht heute um künstliche Intelligenz.
Damit bin ich ja schon wieder raus. Natürliche Intelligenz ist dagegen natürlich. Was qualifiziert euch denn hier Stellung zu beziehen, zu diesem Thema eigentlich? Ich hatte das Auto, ich bin hier rausgefahren.
Du hast ein Kombi neuerdings, hab ich gesehen.
Dich hab ich nicht neuerdings.
Hattest du nicht früher ein Coupé? Da verwechsel ich irgendwas.
Ich dachte, du hattest ein Coupé gehabt.
Nee, es ist ein schöner 1993er Bands Kombi, heißt Matilda. Mein Neid sei mit dir. Was fährst du für ein Auto?
Um hier mal ein bisschen so ein Boulevard.
So einen kleinen Popel-Opel.
Oh, ein Opel?
Den hat die Schwiegermama uns vererbt.
Ja, okay, gut, das ist dann für lau. Also, es gibt Angebote, die kann man nicht ablehnen.
So ungefähr. Ich bin sehr dankbar.
Aber was qualifiziert denn den Joscha, um hier zu sitzen?
Ich bin irgendwann mal in die Uni gegangen, weil ich rauskriegen wollte, wie denken funktioniert. Und ich bin dann da geblieben. Und hab dann eine ganze Weile so Philosophie und Informatik studiert und dann Kognitionswissenschaft gemacht, Kognitivarchitektur programmiert und so was. Und ab und zu gehe ich zu Konferenzen oder organisiere welche zum Thema Künstliche Intelligenz.
Was ist passiert, dass du dir gedacht hast, ich will jetzt wissen, wie denken funktioniert?
Also die meisten denken ja einfach so vor sich hin.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach eine der spannendsten Fragen, die einem so einfällt. Ja klar, aber du musst erst mal drauf kommen.
Gab es irgendwie so einen Schlüssel im Moment?
Nö, ich glaube, dass die meisten Leute, wenn sie anfangen, darüber nachzudenken, was ist der Mensch, dann stellen sie fest, der Mensch ist ein denkendes Wesen, das unterscheidet uns irgendwie von den Enten und Steinen. Und was ist das eigentlich? Was macht das aus? Wie kann es sein, dass irgendein System fühlen und denken kann und wahrnehmen und sich das vorstellen und was ausdenken und fantasieren und träumen und so fort?
Ist künstliche Intelligenz, denkt künstliche Intelligenz?
Hat das was mit Denken zu tun?
Ja, es geht vor allem darum, was rauszukriegen. Und der beste Weg ist nicht, dass man sich an einen grünen Tisch setzt und nur philosophiert, weil dann macht man alles falsch, sondern man muss es bauen. Philosophiert hat wenig mit der Realität zu tun. Eigentlich ursprünglich schon immer. Also Philosophie war ja der Versuch, die Welt rauszukriegen. Und irgendwann hat sich das spezialisiert.
Immer wenn einer was Sinnvolles gefunden hat, ist eine eigene Wissenschaft rausgeworden.
Genau, und Philosophen sind einfach die, die im Raum geblieben sind, weil sie nichts Vomutiges gelernt haben.
Weil alle anderen, die was Vomutiges gelernt haben, sind rausgegangen und haben was anderes gemacht. Was ist denn Intelligenz? Denkfähigkeit. Aber was ist dann Denken?
Das ist eine ganz schwierige Frage.
Hast du rausgefunden, wie das Denken funktioniert mittlerweile? Oder suchst du immer noch?
Ich glaube, ich suche natürlich immer noch, aber ich habe eine ganz gute Idee, in welche Richtung man suchen muss. Und diese Frage, was Denken ganz genau ist, hat die KI immer beschäftigt. Und die falschen Antworten, die wir gegeben haben, haben wir uns in falsche Richtungen geführt. Also zum Beispiel hat man gedacht, so etwas wie Schachspielen, dafür muss man unbedingt denken können. Also wenn man Schach spielen kann, dann kann man denken. Und dann haben wir Systeme gebaut, die Schach spielen konnten und haben festgestellt, das sind Schach spielende Toaster. Dann haben wir Fußball genommen. Vielleicht ist es ja Fußball, da haben wir so eine offene Welt und das alles unscharfer und wir haben viele verschiedene mit dem erlangen.
Die lange noch nicht offen.
Ja, aber wir haben halt Fußball spielende Toaster gekriegt. Und Google baut jetzt autofahrende Toaster, ist total toll natürlich.
Kann man nicht mal vielleicht autofahrende Toaster beim Fußball spielen Schach spielen?
Das ist doch irgendwie hochkomplexe.
Aber ich glaube, am Ende kommt das irgendwie auch die Frage hinaus, wie wir denn Intelligenz eigentlich selber wahrnehmen und wie wir sie messen. Das heißt, wie nehmen wir bei irgendeinem Gegenüber, mit dem wir interagieren, ab wann denken wir denn, das ist irgendwie Intelligenz. Also wenn ich irgendwie mit meinem Drucker interagiere, dann ist immer kurz vor der Diplomarbeit, ist dieses blöde Miststück. Wir will mir eins auswischen und da ist ja bestimmt irgendwie eine Art von Intelligenz dahinter.
Ja, weil die ist nicht im Drucker, sondern die schwebt in deiner Wohnung, weil da mal jemand ermordet wurde, spukend rum oder so.
Spaß beiseite. Irgendwie ist ja Intelligenz irgendwie so ein Attribut, was wir dem Gegenüber dann zugestehen. Meistens, indem wir direkt im Gespräch mit ihm sind. Gut, vielleicht sehen wir dann, dass vielleicht ein bisschen viel Vorschussvertrauen gewesen ist, bloß weil es ein Mensch ist.
Wir gehen aber erstmal davon aus, dass jeder Mensch intelligent ist.
Aber was meinen wir eigentlich damit, wenn wir das sagen? Aber wir sehen ja nicht unbedingt im Moment den Menschen, mit denen wir interagieren. Also wenn du anfängst mit jemandem zu chatten zum Beispiel und das dann auf eine Art und Weise runterdampft, indem wir dann nur noch auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise mit ihm kommunizieren, die auch ein Computer problemlos zumindest erzeugen kann, dann fängt das mal an in so einer Konversation. Genau, dann sitzt du in den 80er Jahren im Technikmuseum in Westberlin und sprichst mit einem Computer und denkst, krass, so ist mir passiert damals. Wie hieß das Ding? Eliza, ne? Ja, und das hab ich nicht verstanden. Hast du Eliza nicht verstanden?
Also ich hab gewusst, was das ist, aber ich hab nicht verstanden, wie das das macht, dass es mit mir spricht.
Woher weiß das das, hab ich immer gedacht. Hast du ihm vorher gesagt? Ja, ich weiß.
Heute weiß ich das, aber damals war ich halt...
Da gab's doch jetzt auch jemanden, der Eliza zusammengeknotet hat mit irgendeiner anderen AI im Internet und die haben sich auch irgendwie auch eine halbe Stunde echt super unterhalten.
Bis sie voneinander gemerkt haben, dass sie nicht echt sind.
Das merken sie halt nicht. Das ist das Ding. Die verstehen das nicht. Und die Frage ist, wie können wir im System das Verstehen beibringen? Also wie machen wir einen Test, dass ein System etwas verstanden hat? Ich kann zum Beispiel Eliza nicht sagen, mach doch mal ein Gedicht über folgendes Thema und dann erklär mir, warum du genau so dieses Gedicht gemacht hast. Und jetzt mach's doch mal ein bisschen anders, weil ich hab folgende Idee, bau das mal ein und reflektier darüber, warum das so ist. Das kann Eliza nicht.
Ist das der Trick, solche Systeme auch zu prüfen, solche Systeme auszuhebeln?
Also wenn irgendwas anfängt mit mir zu interagieren, dass ich erst mal sag, dichte mir mal was mit Äpfeln?
Ich muss einfach irgendwas fragen, was echtes Verständnis erfordert. Und dann wird es schwierig, wenn diese Diskussion nicht vorher gescriptet wird im System.
Aber rein theoretisch könnte ich doch diese Diskussion auch skripten.
Oder? Wenn du vorher weißt, was wir sagen, Wort für Wort.
Ich kann ja die gesamte Wikipedia da reinkippen und anfangen das miteinander irgendwie in Verbindung zu bringen. Das ist auch so ein Ansatz, da kommen wir glaube ich später noch dazu ab, wann das Zusammenführen von Dingen, die an sich ja schon ein bisschen Intelligenz darstellen, so wie das Internet, wie einfach das anzuzapfen, wie vielleicht schummeln ist, wenn man als intelligent gelten möchte.
Also ich renn durch mein Leben und behaupte, so damit ich verstehe, oder um Intelligenz von Nichtintelligenz abzugrenzen, stelle ich mir immer einfach vor, okay, Intelligenz ist, wenn ich mir meiner selbst bewusst bin. Reicht das?
Ist das schon Intelligenz?
Schwierig zu sagen, also es ist und bestimmt gehört es mir dazu. Ich glaube, dass Hunde sich ihrer selbst auch bewusst sind und trotzdem können Hunde keine grammatische Sprache lernen und sich keine Computer ausdenken. Und insofern sind Hunde irgendwie intelligent, aber anders als Menschen. Und ich glaube zum großen Teil auch weniger als Menschen. Was die Psychologen messen mit Intelligenz, das ist die Fähigkeit Puzzles zu lösen. Und die Menschen fallen in relativ engen Bereichen dabei. Also im Bereich, wo die Hunde meistens nicht drin sind. Und es gibt auch wenig, was besser Puzzles lösen kann als Menschen. Aber es gibt etwas, was besser Puzzles lösen kann als Menschen. Kommt auf das Puzzle an. Also zum Beispiel diesen Raven-Test, das ist einer von den Intelligenztests. Da gibt es inzwischen KI-Programme, die können den viel besser lösen als Menschen. Wie geht der Raven-Test? Also was macht man da? Das sind meistens geometrische Folgen, die man vervollständigen muss.
Oh, schlimm, kann ich nicht. Ich bin ein Hund.
Nein, nein, das ist nicht so schwer.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich da sitze, denke ich, oh, und gehe.
Es ist eher so ein bisschen Regelmäßigkeiten erkennen. Es ist aber wirklich nicht mehr als das Puzzles lösen und seine Intuitionen dabei spielen lassen, was kommt jetzt als nächstes und das möglichst schnell und exakt. Das ist eine Form von Mustererkennung in dem Fall.
Aber der Intelligenzbegriff an sich hat ja auch über die letzten Jahre eine Diversifizierung erfahren, dass man inzwischen nicht mehr wie intelligente und wenige intelligente Menschen versucht zu unterscheiden, sondern dort auch eher Intelligenz in anderen Bereichen. Es gibt nämlich die emotionale, soziale Intelligenz. Und da kommen wir dann auch darauf hin, dass ein Professor, der sich auf ein Thema so eingeschossen hat, kann die einfachsten Dinge im Leben nicht mehr selber, kriegt es mit dem Einkaufen nicht hin, mit der Interaktion mit den Menschen. Und man würde ihn dann für einen Deppen abstempeln. Aber es sind halt mehrere Bereiche, in denen man sich glaubt.
Genau, die soziale Intelligenz ist so ein Trostpreis für die. Ich wollte gerade sagen, sind das valide Kategorien, in denen auch wissenschaftlich gedacht wird?
Oder sind das eher so Kategorien aus der GQ? Das heißt Soft Skills und ist manchmal auch ganz nützlich. Ja, Soft Skills ist auch das, was die Berater für viel Geld den Leuten in den Unternehmen verkaufen, die es eigentlich von alleine wissen sollten.
Das möchten die Leute gerne hören. Es ist super schick, verkauft sich gut, verkauft sich auch gut in der Wissenschaft.
Was macht ihr da für Faxen? Ich wollte nur Joscha nehmen, der gerade noch in alle Richtungen spricht, aber nicht ins Mikrofon.
Ich regle hier so ein bisschen nach, das funktioniert schon ganz gut. Das Lack ist auch weggegangen, also es ist weniger geworden subjektiv. Das Lack? Ja, ich hör meine Stimme mit ein bisschen Verzögerung.
Oh, das kann man erinnern.
Ach so, ich dachte, das wäre...
Siehst du die Knöpfe da?
Das könnte die Hustenmedizin sein.
Da leuchtet ein Knopf, da ist ein F drauf.
Und da ist ein Knopf daneben und eins runter, Wort und Musik. Jetzt müsste die Latenz weg sein.
Hammer. Ich fühl mich gut.
Ja, man wird verrückt davon.
Die Nachrichtensprecher können das.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die das machen.
Die sind verrückt. Also ich kann das auch nicht. Das ist auch so ein fieser Trick, wenn du irgendjemand in seine eigene Stimme noch mal in seine Richtung mit knapp einer halben Sekunde Verzögerung drauf tust.
Was du dabei machen musst, ist total assi.
Damit kannst du jeden beliebigen in den Wahnsinn treiben.
Ich mach das jetzt mal mit Joscha.
Wenn du einfach auf Augenhöhe mit jemandem sprichst und auf Augenhöhe aufs Ohr guckst, einfach nur aufs Ohr gucken, weil dann guckst du nämlich wie so ein Bekloppter die ganze Zeit an dem vorbei, kannst aber auf alle Gesichtsregungen reagieren.
Das heißt, du unterhältst dich ganz normal mit jemandem, aber der denkt, irgendwas würde nicht stimmen. Und wenn du da dann noch so eine Latenz dazu tust...
Wenn du dann noch anfängst, nicht mehr zu blinken... Ja, aber das tut dir irgendwann weh. Ach.
Wie kommen wir jetzt da wieder raus? Ich glaube, wir Nerds sind da total im Vorteil, weil wir haben so wenig emotionale und soziale Intelligenz, dass wir das gar nicht merken, wenn das jemand nicht anguckt.
Ihr guckt sowieso immer aneinander vorbei.
Es ist wie im Skype, Herr Yeh, der guckt da auch nicht mehr ins Gesicht. Und wenn das Bild freest, ich mach das manchmal einfach nicht, im Skype einfach so nicht zu bewegen und dann die Gegenseite denkt, scheiße, wiedergefressen gefroren.
Nicht zu bewegen und dann von irgendeinem Recorder Artefakte einspielen.
Aber wir sind jetzt schon abgeschwiffen.
Ja, ist schon leid.
Wo kamen wir denn jetzt her?
Vielleicht, wir kamen uns das Stichwort aufgeschwiffen. Ja, wir sollten das vielleicht mal irgendwie versuchen zu strukturieren oder?
Ich bin ja immer noch dabei, Intelligenz definiert zu kriegen.
Also woran erkenne ich Intelligenz?
Dass sie Puzzle lösen kann.
Ich sollte immer einen Puzzle dabei haben.
Ich glaube, dass wir ein bisschen den Fokus verschoben haben, ist, dass wir am Anfang dachten in der Forschung, dass was wir rauskriegen müssen, sind die High-End-Leistungen von Menschen. Also was halt Erwachsene, die besonders schlau sind, besonders gut können. Und das müssen wir programmieren und abtesten. Dann festgestellt, viele von diesen Dingen können wir einzeln programmieren und abtesten. Aber was wir eigentlich hinkriegen müssen, ist die Grundfunktionalität, die das überhaupt erst ermöglicht. Also wie bauen wir ein System, das sich wie so ein Baby seinen Weg zum Intelligenzsein selbst bahnt. Das in eine Welt rausgeht und Sachen anschaut und da Ordnung reinbringt in die Welt, die strukturiert für sich Konzepte entwickelt, Sprache lernt, mit anderen interagiert und anfängt Probleme zu lösen. Und das irgendwann vielleicht besser macht als ein Mensch.
Bringt denn da die Babys irgendwie noch selber schon was mit in ihrem Gehirn, auf dem man aufbauen kann oder?
Definitiv. Mir ist so aufgefallen, so beim selber Kinder haben, dass dieser Tag, wo die geboren sind, das ist nicht so ein tabula rasa Tag, wo alles von vorne beginnt, sondern die sind da schon eine ganze Weile ziemlich beieinander und das ist der Tag, wo der Kopf wahnsinnig doll gequetscht wird. Also dieses, wie neu geboren ist eine blöde Metapher. Ich glaube, man fühlt sich super scheiße, wenn man neu geboren ist.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das Leben ein Geschenk ist.
Jedenfalls an diesem ersten Tag ist es für die meisten Kinder, glaube ich nicht. Und die haben da schon eine ganze Reihe von Konzepten, wie ihr Körper so aufgebaut ist. Das haben die schon gelernt. Und dann kommen halt neue Arten von Sachen dazu, zum Beispiel, dass es scheiße kalt ist und dass es so Lichtpunkte gibt, die sich bewegen und Kontraste, die sich bewegen. Und dann fangen die an, irgendwann daraus Objekte zu konstruieren. Mit einer Raumvorstellung. Und das ist so ein allmählicher Bootstrapping-Prozess, das setzt sich zusammen. Aber das entsteht nicht dadurch, dass man so einen klumpen Nerven hat und man steckt ein Auge an die eine Seite und Beine an die andere Seite und dann organisiert sich das. Man muss da schon ein bisschen Organisation reinbringen vorher.
Wann habt ihr bemerkt, dass ihr auf einem falschen Dampfer seid?
Immer mal wieder. Also es gab die ganzen guten Ideen von Anfang an. Und dann kommen Leute auf die Idee, okay, jetzt machen wir mal das, was so niedrig hängende Früchte ist, zum Beispiel logikbasierte Systeme. Und dann verselbstständigt sich das. Dann ist irgendeine Methode da, dann kann man da publizieren. Dann gibt es da Studenten, die damit ausgebildet werden, dann wollen die das Gleiche machen, wenn selber Professor. Und irgendwann hat man irgendeine festgefügte Disziplin. Und dann müssen die ganzen guten Ideen neu erfunden werden. Das ist wie Wirtschaftswissenschaften. Schlimmer. Schlimmer? Nee, die Wirtschaftswissenschaften sind noch schlimmer. Das ist einfach andere Interessen als Erkenntnis.
Welche?
Jetzt sind wir wieder abgeschweift.
Ich muss dann eben aufhören. Nein, das ist ja schon einer der Kernpunkte, diese Forschung steht ja da irgendwie heute auch nicht mehr im luftleeren Raum, sondern man muss ja mal versuchen, an den Universitäten da Drittmittel heranzuführen oder erklären, warum das total voll nützlich ist, an dem man da grad forscht. Und da sind ja Geisteswissenschaften und so Grundlagenforschung zuletzt immer schwierig. Wobei künstliche Intelligenz kannst du halt super in die Rüstungsindustrie verkaufen. Die finanzieren da glaube ich jeden Scheiß, wenn du denen erzählst, du kannst was bauen, was sich automatisch tarnt, abhängig davon, welche Armee auf es zukommt.
Das Problem ist, du musst es dann aber irgendwann auch fertig haben, sonst kriegst du kein Geld mehr.
Das willst du ja eigentlich nicht. Ja, aber guck mal, mit diesem Fusionsreaktor klappt das doch auch.
Irgendwann wird da das Geld wieder gecancelt. Das ist ja wirklich so, da muss man von vorne anfangen. Das ist ja auch passiert. Also am Anfang waren die Leute sehr optimistisch. So in den 50er, 60er Jahren haben sie ganz viel in ganz kurzer Zeiten gekriegt. So Systeme, die planen konnten und die einfach in natürliche Sprache verstehen konnten. Schon ein bisschen besser als Eliza, am ganz Ende besser als Eliza, weil das war recht simpel. Und dann dachten sie, okay, das geht in dem Tempo weiter. Und das ging aber nicht in Tempo weiter. Das waren einfach nur die niedrig hängen Früchte. Und da waren dann ganz viele Leute enttäuscht und haben gesagt, da kommt ja nichts bei raus. Also das Funding streichen wir. Und noch dazu ist ja der KI eine totale Zumutung für unsere Kultur. Also mit dem christlichen Menschenbild geht das überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Habt ihr da wirklich Probleme?
Also gibt es da Theologendemonstrationen vor der Universität und solche Sachen?
Na, ich glaube, dass das so eine Sache mit der Allgemeinheit ist. Wir haben mal zum Beispiel so ein Projekt gemacht zusammen mit Philosophen und Neurobiologen. Bei der VW-Stiftung. Wir wollten Emotionen erforschen und wir haben gesagt, es sei also drei Gruppen, eine Gruppe Informatiker, die bauen Computermodelle von unseren Emotionskonzepten, die wir entwickeln. Die Philosophen arbeiten auf der konzeptuellen Ebene. Die Neurobiologen wussten noch nicht so ganz genau, was sie machen. Wir tun Leute in Scanner und beobachten irgendwie Emotionen. Und die VW-Stiftung hat gesagt, super Projekt, aber Computer haben nichts mit Emotionen zu tun. Die können nichts damit zu tun haben. Also das tun wir bitte raus.
Das haben die einfach so gesagt.
Nun ist die VW-Stiftung, die Gruppe, eher geisteswissenschaftlich veranlagt gewesen. Aber ich glaube, dass wir so einen Konsens haben im Abendland, der gegen den Mechanismus geht. Also gegen diese Vorstellung, dass die Welt im Grunde mechanisch ist. Das geht ja. Aber die Vorstellung, dass alles mechanisch ist, also auch unsere Gedanken und Gefühle und unsere Seelen, das ist eine Zumutung. Stimmt.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Wie habt ihr es trotzdem geschafft, Geld von denen zu kriegen oder habt ihr es nicht geschafft?
Von der VW-Stiftung in dem Falle haben wir das nicht geschafft. Also jedenfalls nicht für die Informatikteile. Das ist aber nicht so schlimm. Es gibt ja immer eine Chance, dass Forschungsprojekte fehlen und vielleicht war auch einfach unser Teil da nicht gut genug, den wir eingereicht haben. Ich glaube viel. Also ich rede immer wieder mit KI-Leuten, die ganz optimistisch sind, weil sie meinen, wenn jetzt mein Projekt umgesetzt wird, dann klappt das und ich brauche zwar viel Geld und dann reden die von, sagen wir mal so 10 Millionen oder so und dann denke ich als Informatiker drüber nach, also nicht als Akademiker und denke, hey, dafür kannst du kein ordentliches Start-up auf die Beine stellen. Dafür kannst du nicht mal die Garderobe von Sex und the City Teil 2 kaufen.
10 Millionen, da kriegst du ein gutes CMS für.
Und du weißt noch nicht mehr genau, was du da machst. Es ist einfach nur für dich verdammt viel Geld.
Wo bleibt das Geld denn da wirklich? Ich meine, das sind ja größtenteils Personalkosten, die du an so einem Start-up verbrennst. Was ist dann an der Universität, wenn du dieses Projekt...
Das ist auch alles Personalkosten.
Irgendjemand muss den Krempel ja zusammen coden. Studenten. Hier hat gerade einer angerufen, hat sich beschwert, die Hintergrundmusik würde nerven. Soll ich ausmachen oder anlassen? Hat er angerufen sogar? Hat er angerufen sogar, ja. Ich würde ja gerne im IRC mal nachfragen, aber ich komm da grad nicht rein.
Du musst dann... Ich könnte dir...
Ich hab hier Internet, aber ich komm nicht rein, weil mein Irk-Server tot ist grad.
Ach so. Wieso hast du Internet?
Ich hab Mobiltelefon. Ja, aber das ist doch verboten im Hörfungsstudio.
Jetzt wissen wir gar nicht...
Können wir gar nicht in den Chat fragen, sowas doof ist aber auch. Was ich ja gerne mal wissen würde, ist wie habt ihr euch das denn dann, wie modelliere ich Intelligenz in einen Computer rein? Also überhaupt, wie modelliere ich Intelligenz? Wie testest du dann am Ende, ob du Erfolg gehabt hast? Also ich glaub, ich schmeiß den Puzzle hin und wenn es das lösen kann, dann hat es das gelöst. Dann ist es intelligent gewesen, oder? Nimm mal irgendeinen Menschen, der wie von so einem Konzept vom Puzzle keine Ahnung hat, den musst du ja irgendwie auch erst langsam drauf hinarbeiten, was ein Puzzle ist, wann er Erfolg hatte, den Puzzle zu lösen. Nee, das mach ich über Konditionierung. Wenn er das richtig zusammengesteckt hat, kriegt er einen Zirkuschen, ansonsten kriegt er Elektroschocks. Aber weißt du, der sagt, du brauchst am Ende einen Aktor, der dir Dinge vermittelt mit so einem Puzzle, der entweder mit dir spricht oder eine Ausgabe irgendwo hin hat, der also in dem Medium, in dem du ihn wahrnimmst, dir vermitteln kann, dass es sich dabei um eine Intelligenz handelt, irgendwie die denkt.
Vielleicht gibt es ja auch Aufgaben, wo man ganz schwer cheaten kann. Also zum Beispiel guck dir meinen Film ein. Guck dir einen Film an von Rotkäppchen. Und dann erzähl mir mal, nachdem du den Film zum ersten Mal gesehen hast, das kann ich ja überprüfen, indem ich dein Gedächtnis gucke, wenn du in der KI bist.
Achso, wenn ich in der KI bin? Ich dachte gerade, du könntest in mein Gedächtnis gucken.
Wenn du in der KI bist. Vielleicht ist das hier eine Simulation.
Ich hab vier Semester Psychologie und alle haben gedacht, ich könnte Gedanken lesen.
Ich hab nur drei geschafft.
War das nicht auf?
Was machst du denn?
Psychologie?
Ich bin nichtmals zur Prüfung gegangen.
Ja, aber ist ja egal.
Hauptsache man studiert Psychologie und alle glauben sofort, du könntest Gedanken lesen.
So, ich bin also eine KI und...
Du guckst Rotkäppchen. Ich frag dich jetzt, sag mal, warum meint der das Rotkäppchen, dass es jetzt den anderen Weg geht, nachdem der Wolf das gesagt hat. Und warum hat der Wolf zu dem Rotkäppchen gesagt, dass es den anderen Weg gehen soll? Was glaubst du denn, was der Wolf denkt, dass das Rotkäppchen denkt, wenn der Wolf das zu dem Rotkäppchen sagt und so weiter? Spiegelneuronen. Da kann ich zum Beispiel testen, hat derjenige ein Konzept von einer Theory of Mind, also hat er ein Konzept davon, dass der Wolf Beliefs über die Beliefs vom Rotkäppchen hat und konnte die inferieren aus dem Film. Und das ist glaube ich, also rauskriegen, folgern, aus dem, was er in dem Film gesehen hat. Also einfach dadurch, dass er Bilder gesehen hat, sich bewegt haben und sich münder bewegt haben und dann gleichzeitig Geräusche ertönt, konnte der da raus Schlüsse ziehen über Dinge, die der Wolf glaubt über das Rotkäppchen. Und zwar über die mentalen Zustände, die das Rotkäppchen hat. Also das, was das Rotkäppchen wiederum glaubt. Und was hat das mit dem, was Rotkäppchen üblicherweise glauben zu tun? Also was macht das denn normalerweise? Und so weiter und so fort. Und warum glaubt dann der Wolf, dass er eine Chance hat, wenn er das erzählt und so weiter? Was bedeutet das denn, wenn der hungrig ist? Warum motiviert ihn, das Rotkäppchen reinzulegen? Und so weiter und so fort. Und das sind Dinge, die kann ich auch mit kleinen Kindern testen. Ich kann einfach gucken, mit zwei Jahren verstehen die das und das, mit drei Jahren kann ich das und das, mit vier das und das. Und wenn wir Systeme so weit bringen würden, dass sie in so einen Wettbewerb teilnehmen können, dann könnten wir die tatsächlich mit Menschenkindern vergleichen und gucken, bis zu welcher Stufe die kommen.
Wie weit seid ihr?
Wir sind noch nicht mal so richtig in den Anfang. Also es geht gerade erst los.
Das heißt, der Bischof muss sich noch nicht Sorgen machen. Weil ich glaube, das würde eine Ethikdiskussion auslösen, die sich gewaschen hätte, oder?
Ich glaube, für die Christen selber ist das gar nicht so sehr schlimm. Aber die meisten Leute haben ja so eine Intuition. Unsere Welt, die wir jetzt haben, die ist wie World of Warcraft. Und da gibt es so dieses Spielgeld und so weiter und so fort. Und es gibt Aufgaben und es gibt Bäume und so fort. Das ist alles in dem Spiel drin, in der physikalischen Welt. Aber wir selber sitzen draußen. Unsere Seelen sitzen draußen und spielen in dieser Welt. Und diese echte Welt, das ist da, wo unsere Gefühle und Seelen sind. Wir können Gott abstrahieren davon. Gott ist so im Prinzip der Programmierer von dem. Der hatte die Ruthrechte, das alles damals umgesetzt. Der Teufel übrigens hat auch Ruthrechte. Das ist aber bloß ein Hacker, der hat so eine Division von Gott. Die können wir subtrahieren davon, von dieser Vision. Aber zu sagen, ihr seid alle NPCs, ihr seid alles bloß Non-Player-Characters, nur Figuren in diesem Spiel, die komplett im Computer sind, die selber Teil von dieser Software sind, selber Teil von diesem Spiel sind, das ist für die meisten Leute so einfach.
Ja, läuft da rein.
Es geht um künstliche Intelligenz. Und selbstverständlich seid ihr auch eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Falls euch was einfällt oder auffällt, was zum Thema passt und uns vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen weiterbringen.
Vielleicht habt ihr es ja im Fun-Sinn gesehen oder im Radio oder Fun gehört. Für diesen Song hier haben sie gerade den Grammy für den besten Song des Jahres eingesagt. Und jetzt kommen sie nach Berlin.
So lange es noch Karten gibt.
Immer gute neue Musik.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Chaosradio 187 zur künstlichen Intelligenz ist hier. Erdgeist und Joscha im Studio. Wo wollten wir weitermachen? Siehst du genau, wir wollten über die Geschichte noch mal reden.
Also meine erste künstliche Intelligenz war Eliza, hatte ich ja eben schon mal erzählt.
Da war ich 86 oder 87 auf Klassenfahrt in Berlin. Und da sind wir ins Technikmuseum gegangen. Da stand so ein Terminal rum, da konnte man das machen.
Das hat mich sehr fasziniert, aber doch nicht genug fasziniert, um dann vielleicht auch irgendwie Hacker zu werden.
Aber wie kam denn das, dass es dich fasziniert hat?
Na ja, das war halt eine Maschine, die mit mir geredet hat und so getan hat, als würde sie nicht mich verstehen. Na ja, schon irgendwie auf mich eingehen halt.
Also Empathie wieder.
Verstehen, und das hast du vorher nicht gehabt. Vorher hast du nur am BTX irgendwie mit...
C64 Elite gespielt oder so ein Scheiß.
Und warum bist du da nicht drauf gekommen, dass da vielleicht hinter irgendwas noch eine Intelligenz stecken könnte? Na, weil ich mir nie Gedanken darüber gemacht habe, wie so ein Ding überhaupt funktioniert.
Also das war halt wirklich Load-Spielname, 8, 1 und gib ihm. Aber mehr hab ich mit Computer nie getan.
Aber weißt du denn inzwischen, wie Eliza funktioniert hat?
Zumindest theoretisch weiß ich es. Also wie das programmiert ist natürlich nicht, aber dass das Ding darauf wartet, dass ich Schlüsselwörter liefere und mich dann nach diesen Schlüsselwörtern befragt, das hab ich so einigermaßen möglich.
Weil das Ding fragt ja glaube ich nur, wenn ich mich recht entsinne. Na es fragt und setzt dann immer noch schlau die Antworten, die du früher gegeben hast, wieder zusammen. Das war ja auch die Sekretärin des Professors, die damals Eliza geschrieben hatte, haben sich da auch nächtelang mit diesem Eliza unterhalten und fanden, dass sie total tolle Gespräche geführt haben. Als dann rausgekommen ist, dass das gar keine Person war, sondern ein Computer und dann noch Logs existieren, die müssen mal weg, da haben sie sich dann auch so sehr demgegenüber geöffnet, dass da irgendwie schon so ein Test auf Intelligenz da wohl schon funktioniert hat. Das hatte ja schon Alan Turing formalisiert gehabt. Der hatte irgendwann mal erzählt, dass ja, bevor man sich da irgendwie auseinandersetzt, was dann Intelligenz heißt, sollte man sich vorher mal im Klaren werden, woran man das feststellt, und dann hat er gesagt, die Regeln sind ganz einfach. Man setzt sich einfach hin in den Raum und kommuniziert mit irgendjemand anders über irgendein Medium, wo es halt dem Computer einfach ist zu antworten, also wo man nicht gleich sieht, dass er Schwierigkeiten hat, Stimme zu synthetisieren, sondern einfach als Text. Und wenn man sich da in einem einstündigen Gespräch davon überzeugen lässt, dass auf der anderen Seite sich ein Mensch sitzt, dann hat was immer dort mit einem kommuniziert, diesen Touring-Test bestanden und ist dann eine wirkliche, als künstliche Intelligenz zu wirken. Wie würde ich denn eigentlich, gibt es irgendwie die eine Frage oder den einen Trick, um rauszufinden, ob ich mit einem Computer oder einem Menschen zu tun habe?
Nee, dann könnte ich es ja programmieren. Und es gibt eine Bachelor-Verb jedes Jahr, der Lübner-Preis, wo genau so was stattfindet, wo eine Jury versucht, rauszukriegen, ob das Programm fake ist, also ob da ein Mensch auf der anderen Seite vom Terminal ist oder ein Programm. Und die Programme werden jedes Jahr besser. Ich habe neulich mit meiner Krankenkasse gechattet.
Kommt drauf an, die übernehmen dann irgendwann. Also die machen am Anfang die Standardfragen, werden von noch einer Maschine beantwortet. Meistens reicht das schon aus. Und wenn du dann irgendwann mal eskalieren musst, weil das Problem komplexer ist, was die Maschine noch mit Standardantworten machen kann, dann sieht ein Mitarbeiter auf seinem Screen den Fall auf der Konversation, liest dann noch mal kurz drüber und übernimmt dann.
Wenn du mit jemandem vom Ebay bist, dann hast du das Gefühl, das kann nicht mein Computer sein, weil die Folgen so stur hier im Skript.
Da ist dann auch der Unterschied nicht mehr so groß. Das meinte ich wohl mit, wenn du auf Chatroulette rumgehst, ich glaube, 90 Prozent der Leute dort würden auch einfach den Touringtest nicht bestehen. Du kannst ja eigentlich irgendwann, wenn du so Mensch bist, dann auch sagen, keine Ahnung, was machst du da, wie blöde Fragen, langweilt nicht und einfach aufhören. Und an der Stelle, ja, so was könntest du am Computer ja auch einfach beibringen. Und dann hast du dieses Gespräch dann beendet, weil du dich dann wie gerade analysiert fühlst als Mensch und würdest dann den Touringtest dann wahrscheinlich auch verlieren. Würdest du die Rotkäppchen-Nummer von vorhin funktionieren?
Nee, die würde nicht funktionieren. Jedenfalls nicht, wenn das System so eine komplexe Aufgabe machen muss, dass es ein Narrativ verstehen muss, das es vorher nicht kannte. Also wenn ich in den Test auf jeden Fall mit aufnehme, dass es diese Sachen vorher nicht kennt und ich weiß, welche Fragen gestellt werden, sodass es dann die abspulen kann in einer weniger raffinierten Weise. Ich kann ja wahnsinnig viele Daten reintun. Computer hat Jeopardy gewonnen inzwischen, weil ich das ganze Wissen vorher reintun konnte.
Aber was heißt denn dieses Wissen da vorher reintun?
Nein, nein, nein, aus, aus.
Du steckst ja nicht einfach so die DVD ins Laufwerk und dann hast du jetzt irgendwie die Wikipedia da geladen, sondern du brauchst ja schon Modelle von diesem Wissen, das dann am Ende beflügelt deine...
Ja, in dem Augenblick ist es sogar eigentlich gar kein richtiges Wissen, sondern sozusagen wissensähnliches Zeug. Es ist hinreichend analog in seiner Struktur zu wissen, damit es dabei durchgeht, wenn ein Mensch das anschaut. Diese Idee von Eliza, die ist ja total alt. Im Grunde genommen hat die ETA. Hoffmann beschrieben schon. Den kennt ihr so einen Schriftsteller aus der Romantik. Der hat einen Wissenschaftler namens Balanzani sich ausgedacht. Der hat auch ein historisches Vorbild und so. Aber egal, dieser Wissenschaftler in einem seiner Romane baut der einen Androiden. Und zwar ist dieser Androide clevererweise eine Frau. Also ein weiblicher Roboter. Und dieser weibliche Roboter, der hat kein großes Konversationstalent, aber er kann mit den Augen klappern und sagen, hach. Und der begegnet einem jungen Mann, und der unterhält sich längere Zeit sehr angeregt mit diesem weiblichen, sehr nicht anzusehenden Roboter und versichert danach glaubhaft, dass er noch nie so gut verstanden wurde wie von diesem System. Und in einer ähnlichen Weise funktioniert ja Eliza. Ist ja an dieser algorithmischen Gesprächstherapie angelehnt. Also an einer Kunst zuzuhören, die in therapeutischen Sitzungen eingesetzt wird, wo aber der Patient im Grunde genommen alles selber sagt. Also das Ding wird einem nicht erklären, was man tun soll, sondern man hat eine Möglichkeit immer weiter zu elaborieren. Und das reicht den meisten Leuten für die Konversation aus. Aber wir sind ja anders hingekommen vielleicht. Ich war ja auch C64-Haber, so wie du. Und da ich im Osten war, hat es eine Weile gedauert, bis ich Spiele hatte. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass ich meine Spiele selber schreiben musste. Und das heißt, wir haben so von der Picke auf überlegt, wie baue ich das immer, wenn wir was angeguckt haben. Und dann ist natürlich dieser Gedanke total naheliegend, wie könnte ich mir was bauen, mit dem ich mich richtig unterhalten könnte. Dass ich mich richtig verstehe. Und zwar nicht, indem ich was erzählen kann, weil ich möchte einfach nur jemanden haben, wo ich da alles reintue und der so tut, als ob er mich versteht, sondern der mir neue Ideen gibt, mit dem ich Ping Pong spielen kann, geistig. Und das bedeutet aber, dass der auch in gewissen Weise mit der Welt ähnlich umgehen muss wie ich. Warum hast du nicht einfach Menschen gesucht? Ich bin im Wald groß geworden, das war total schwierig.
Von Wölfen genährt.
Ich bin in der Großstadt groß geworden, aber so ein Computer war einfach geduldiger mit allen Fehlern, die man macht. Also du kannst da einfach so ewig rumprobieren mal und dann kannst du irgendwie Reset drücken, wenn du es verkackt hast. Ich hab mir viele Feinde gemacht, weil ich mehr mit Menschen...
Ja, das bringt es nicht.
Das bringt es nicht. Heute hab ich noch in einen Chat geschrieben, Menschen sind doch wirklich das Letzte. Aber was ziehen unsere Hörer da gerade für eine Lehre raus?
Menschen sind das Letzte.
Ja, und es lohnt einfach nicht, sich mit denen auseinanderzusetzen. Holt euch lieber einen Computer und versucht, eure eigene künstliche Intelligenz zu programmieren.
So sieht es aus.
Habt ihr das schon mal gemacht?
0331 77 97 110.
Kann ja sein, dass ihr die erste Schritte im Programmieren der künstlichen Intelligenz schon mal gedingst habt. Wie ich sage, wollen wir mal einen Anrufer rannehmen?
Lass mal einen Anrufer rannehmen.
Und zwar habe ich eine Frage zu diesem Rotkäppchenbeispiel, das ihr da gerade gebracht habt. Und zwar würde mich interessieren, inwieweit ihr der Meinung seid, dass dann eine KI überhaupt dazu fähig ist, jemals Gefühle zu begreifen, in irgendeiner Art und Weise, ob jetzt logisch oder halt wie auch immer geartet mental, und wie das denn vonstatten gehen könnte.
Na da sind wir dann ganz schnell bei dem Thema, wie du Gefühle und Intelligenz zusammenbringst und wie du dann wirklich Gefühle definierst und wo das rauskommt und ab wann du dann auf der anderen Seite wieder überzeugt bist, dass jemand auf der anderen Seite nicht nur Gefühle selber emuliert und dann durch dieses Nachspielen versuchen kann, diese Muster solange mal zu applizieren, bis es so ungefähr so aussieht, wie das, was er da erwartet, hast du eigentlich dasselbe Problem wie mit der Intelligenz?
Das ist aber genau die Knackfrage. Also für die meisten Leute ist die Vorstellung, dass so ein System irgendwelche logischen Schlüsse zieht, total nachvollziehbar, aber dass es fühlt zum Beispiel. Also im Sinne von Hell, ne? Gefühle haben, so richtig, ich spüre das. Was bedeutet das eigentlich? Das bringt uns zu der Frage, was sind denn überhaupt Gefühle?
Also, ja, wenn man jetzt mal Gefühle ganz rein wissenschaftlich, biologisch als, sagen wir mal, da werden irgendwelche Hormone ausgeschüttet und so weiter oder meinetwegen auch Unwohlbewusstsein aufgrund von irgendwelchen Erfahrungen, die man gemacht hat, wäre es rein theoretisch möglich, einer Maschine beizubringen oder auch eine Maschine selbstständig das begreifen zu lassen, dass es dieser Form von Gefühlen nachvollziehen, wenn ich sogar auch nachahmen kann.
Ja klar, aber dabei wäre es mir wichtig, die Hormone selber sind nicht wichtig. Gefühle sind ja nichts Schemisches. Autofahren ist ja auch nicht, wenn Benzin ausgeschüttet wird. Sondern das Benzin, das benutzt das Auto, nur um sich vorzubewegen und da irgendwas in Drehung zu versetzen. Und man könnte auch was anderes nehmen, zum Beispiel Strom. Und in unserem Fall ist das Entscheidende nicht so sehr, dass da eine bestimmte Chemie da sein muss, sondern das Entscheidende ist, dass es auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise rechnen muss. Unser Gehirn, das ist nämlich eigentlich meiner Ansicht nach ein Rechner. Das besteht aus diesen ganzen hunderten von Milliarden von Neuronen. Und alles, was die tun die ganze Zeit, ist, die tauschen Informationen aus.
Und fummeln dabei auch noch an sich selber rum. Also die Möglichkeit, bestimmte Verbindungen abzubauen, aufzubauen.
Solche Chips haben wir inzwischen auch. Aber das Ding ist, was ist da dann ein Gefühl? Wie kann da ein Gefühl reinkommen? Und das ist genau so eine große Frage. Also Leibniz hat zum Beispiel gesagt, stellt euch mal vor, dass der Geist wie so eine Art Mühle ist. Und wir machen die ganz groß und können da reingehen. Und wir sehen da lauter Teile, die einander stoßen und so fort. Und wir sehen, da kann gar nichts fühlen in so einem Mechanismus. Also das muss was ganz anderes sein als ein Mechanismus. Und ähnlich ist das mit dem Computer. Wenn wir den aufvergrößern würden, dann sehen wir halt, wie die ganzen Schaltkreise hin und her schalten. Oder das Gehirn vergrößern und sehen, wie da die ganzen Calciumkanäle auf und zu machen. Und die Neurotransmitter ausgeschüttet werden. Aber die Gefühle können wir da nicht sehen, natürlich nicht. Die Gefühle sind, glaube ich, Konfigurationen. Was ich damit meine ist, wenn wir in einem Gefühlszustand sind, dann verändern sich bestimmte Parameter in unserer Psyche. Zum Beispiel sind wir erregter oder weniger erregt. Wenn wir erregt sind, dann weiten sich halt die Blutgefäße und die Verdauung wird runtergefahren. Das fühlt sich dann auf eine bestimmte Weise an, drückt einen im Magen oder so. Und wir denken schneller, aber mit weniger Auflösung. Das bedeutet, wir kommen schneller zu Ergebnissen, aber wir vermissen ganz viele Details, wenn wir aufgeregt sind. Das ist zum Beispiel einer der Aspekte. Ein anderer ist, ob wir irgendwas gut oder schlecht finden, also ob wir ein positives oder negatives Lusterlebnis haben gerade. Das ist auch eine Dimension dabei, was dazu führt, dass es sich auf eine bestimmte Weise anfühlt. Und dann gibt es so was wie ein Sicherungsverhalten, mit dem wir gucken, wie stark verändert sich dann zur Zeit die Umwelt, wie oft muss ich denn von dem, was ich mache, aufgucken und Umweltreize reinholen, wie stark bin ich introvertiert oder extrivetiert nach außen gerichtet. Und diese Parameter zusammen bringen mich in eine Stimmung. Und diese Stimmung bedeutet, ich nehme die Welt anders wahr. Die sieht jetzt anders aus. Ich verarbeite die Daten, die die Welt mir gibt, anders. Und wenn ich mich selbst reflektiere, dann nehme ich mich selbst auch anders wahr. Ich werde zu einem anderen System. Und ich glaube, dieses Ich werde ein anderer, das ist das, was Gefühle ausmacht. Gefühle sind nicht so eine Variable oder ein Modul oder ein Schaltkreis an unserem Gehirn, sondern Gefühle bedeuten, wir werden zu einem anderen.
Aber das ist doch rein theoretisch und auch nur wieder auf einer Basis von physikalischen Prozessen sowieso, aber auf einer Basis von relativ primitiven Kettenreaktionen, die irgendwie ablaufen. Aber eine solche Kettenreaktion müsste doch rein theoretisch auch, ist ja rein theoretisch sogar heute, würde ich mal die These wagen, schon mit einigen Systemen nachvollziehbar. Das heißt, das würde ja heißen, dass im Prinzip vom Computer uns nichts mehr entscheidet, sondern der Computer nur anders denkt. Und im Prinzip sogar auf eine gewisse Weise auch genauso gefühlvoll oder gefühllos wie wir, oder?
Ja, klar. Nur das Ding ist, dass wir noch keinen Computer gebaut haben, der mit diesen Gefühlen irgendwas Spannendes macht. Das heißt, der nimmt zum Beispiel die Welt nicht groß anders wahr, weil er nicht so gut in Weltwahrnehmung ist. Und der tut nicht so tolle Sachen mit anderen Leuten, weil er überhaupt nicht gut in Sachen mit anderen Leuten tun ist. Und diese Grundfunktionen fehlen. Ich glaube, Gefühle sind im Grunde genommen ziemlich einfach. Das Problem ist, die sind Modulationen von kognitiven Prozessen, also von Wahrnehmungs- und Denkprozessen. Und diese Wahrnehmungs- und Denkprozesse, die sozusagen weniger rätselhaft aussehen, die sind technisch ganz schön verzwickt. Und diese verzwickten Rätsel, die Puzzles, die haben noch nicht alle gelöst, da ist noch ziemlich viel Arbeit zu leisten. Und ich glaube, wenn wir die geleistet haben, das Ding dann so zu modulieren, dass es diese Gefühlszustände durchmacht, das ist nicht das Problem.
Gehst du davon aus, dass wir das irgendwann moduliert gekriegt haben?
Also dass wir irgendwann mal eine richtige künstliche Intelligenz haben?
Oder werden wir da immer dran scheitern, weil es doch zu groß ist?
Ich glaube nicht, dass es so schwierig ist. Also es ist halt, es ist nicht intuitiv. Aber wenn wir uns mal die Komplexität angucken, unser ganzes Genom passt auf eine CD-ROM locker. Das heißt, es ist einfacher als Microsoft Windows.
Wenig Daten, die reingehen und dann viel und schnell rechnen.
Und nur ein ganz kleiner Bruchteil davon codiert unser Gehirn. Und das Gehirn wird dann natürlich ausgepackt mit diesem Wahnsinnsprozess im Mutterleib und später. Und formt sich dann in der Interaktion mit der Umwelt, kriegt dann seinen Feinschliff und so fort und wickelt seine ganzen Drähte auf. Und diesen Prozess zu reverse-ingenieren, das ist nicht ohne Weiteres möglich. Und im Augenblick gehen die Neurobiologen, versuchen ein bisschen zu reverse-ingenieren. Aber für einen Informatiker sieht das, was die Neurobiologen ein bisschen aus, als würde man versuchen, den Vogelflug zu verstehen, indem man Vögel studiert. Aber die Onetologen kriegen die Theorie vom Fliegen nicht raus. Wenn ich mit Mikroskop auf den Vogelflügel gucke, dann seh ich da, oh Gott, da sind ja Millionen von diesen Federkielen. Und jeder von denen hat tausende von kleinen Zäppchen, die ineinander verdrahtet sind mit den Nachbarfedern. Das kriegst du nie modelliert. Und wenn ich das modelliere, dann ähnlich wahrscheinlich mit dem Pinguin. Und das Ding kann gar nicht fliegen. Also ich versuche als Informatiker eher die Grundfunktion zu bauen. Sie haben Festo, dass der dann hingekriegt, diesen Vogel zu bauen.
Die haben dann anders drauf geguckt.
Na, die haben was anderes gebaut. Die haben erst mal versucht, das Prinzip von Gleiten zu kriegen. Und Systeme zu bauen, die gleiten können und einen Antrieb haben. Und dann eine Theorie von Aerodynamik zu entwickeln. Und dann kann man das Ganze erweitern und diese ganzen Feinheiten dazu bauen. Und vor allen Dingen, wenn man so eine Vorstellung hat von Aerodynamik, dann kann man gucken, wie machen denn die Vögel das? Wie nutzen denn die Aerodynamik? Und das muss so ein Vor und Zurück sein zwischen den einzelnen Feldern. Das eine kann ohne das andere nicht auskommen. Aber ich muss die Vögel angucken, natürlich, um das zu verstehen. Aber die Vögel selber verraten es mir nicht.
Nun würde ich ja mal behaupten, dass wir Menschen uns schon ganz gut gegenseitig angeguckt haben und auch eine Vorstellung haben, wie das mit den Gefühlen funktioniert. Gibt es da eigentlich schon irgendwelche Ansätze in der Informatik, da, sag ich jetzt mal, gefühlsbetonte Programme umzusetzen?
Das gibt es total. Aber das Spannende ist, dass die Psychologen anscheinend noch weniger darüber wissen, als die Menschen. Ist dir schon mal aufgefallen, dass es nicht mal ein Handbuch darüber gibt, wie man anständige Beziehungen führt? Ja, aber es gibt keine, die funktionieren. Paar Therapeuten sind Leute, die zum Allgemeinen keine funktionierende Beziehung haben.
Paar Therapeuten sind dazu da, eine sich in Trennung befindende Beziehung so zu trennen, dass es mit möglichst wenig Blutvergießen abgeht.
Aber es ist doch krass, dass wir das nicht rausgekriegt haben. Dass es da so wenig systematische Kenntnisse gibt.
Ich finde da einen von den spannenden Punkten, wie so ein Computer, der nicht so richtig die Möglichkeit hat, mittels Algorithmen visuell auseinanderzunehmen, was da in der Welt vor sich geht, und deswegen einfach nicht genug Reize aufnehmen und verarbeiten kann, weil ihm das Präprozess, also die Vorverarbeitung fehlt, sieht man auch anders, wenn man sich selber in Kulturkreisen plötzlich befindet, wo man auch nicht weiß, worauf man achten muss, und sich plötzlich total socially clumsy, wie heißt das Wort?
Kulturschock, im Grunde ist es ein Kulturschock.
Genau, und so muss man sich einen Computer eigentlich vorstellen. Er weiß halt nicht, wo er hingucken soll, er weiß halt nicht, was da irgendwie gerade was ist, alles ist in der großen Masche. Wenn man vielleicht noch in irgendwelchen Ländern kommt, wo die Leute alle ganz anders aussehen, dann sehen die erst mal alle gleich aus. Ja, wenn ich weiß, was gemeint ist, setze ich meinen Flugzeug, fliege nach Bangkok und bleibe dann mal eine Woche in Bangkok.
Ja, aber es fehlt auch noch viel mehr. Die ganze Struktur ist nicht da. Wir haben assoziatives Denken noch nicht ganz verstanden. Wir haben das Verhältnis von Sprache und Denken nicht komplett aufgedröselt und so weiter.
Ich wollte jetzt erst mal so runterbrechen, dass ich vielleicht jemand was darunter vorstellen kann. Natürlich ist es noch nicht alles.
Ich war auch so ein bisschen unfair gegenüber dem Psychologen. Natürlich haben die Theorien von Emotionen. Aber das Ding ist, dass die Psychologie als Wissenschaft gar keine Theorie von Geist und Denken hat. Und wenn man versucht, so etwas in der Psychologie zu publizieren, gibt es null Punkte dafür. Wie? Warum das denn? Das liegt daran, dass die Psychologie so einen Unfall hatte. Die hatten ja erst mal so Leute wie Freud und so. Das wurde dann vielen Leuten unheimlich, die gesagt haben, wir müssen mal eine richtige Naturwissenschaft werden. Das heißt, wir müssen nur solche Sachen angucken, die man auch richtig beobachten kann und messen kann und nachvollziehbare Experimente. Das ist in der Psychoanalyse verdammt schwierig.
Ist es schwierig? Ist es nicht eher unmöglich?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist halt dieses Spünkigerei. Wir konzentrieren uns genau auf das, was man beobachten kann und das ist Verhalten. Und die Beschäftigung mit Sachen, die man nicht direkt als Verhalten beobachten kann, ist unwissenschaftlich. Und das nennt es sich Herbivorismus. Und davon hat sich Psychologie bis heute nicht ganz erholt. Also da gibt es noch so Reste davon. Und das steckt sich daran nieder, dass psychologische Theorien meistens so formuliert werden müssen, dass man dazu ein Experiment machen kann. Und dieses eine Experiment liefert mir dann irgendwie so eine 80%-Korrelation. Und dann ist meine Hypothese hoffentlich bestätigt. Wiederlegt hätte ich beinahe gesagt, aber es gibt keine Papers, in denen Thesen widerlegt werden. Also diese werden immer bestätigt in der Psychologie.
Ich glaube, du hast auch, wenn du so ein psychologisches Experiment anberaumst, dann musst du ja meistens ein Environment schaffen, was nicht so funktioniert wie draußen. Also meistens pickt man sich irgendeine Verhaltensweise raus, die man untersuchen möchte, dann holt man die Leute in sein Labor und dann lässt man die so Dinge tun. Und jetzt, die letzte Woche erst wieder von diesen Wirtschaftspsychologen, wie so einige von den Dingen, wo sie gesagt haben, dass ich ja Banker und Broker und wir alle total irrational verhalten und wir haben es so wie getestet, sind eigentlich auch nur Artefakte gewesen von den Verhaltensbeobachtungen dann im Labor, sodass du auch isoliert irgendeinen Menschen da herzunehmen und ihm verbietest, zusätzliche Hinweise zu nehmen, die ja normalerweise noch mit versteckt sind in so einer Kommunikation. Da war so eins von diesen Fehlwahrnehmungen, dass wenn der Arzt dir erzählt, es gibt eine 95%ige Erfolgsquote für deine Operation, ist es was anderes, als wenn er dir sagt, es gibt irgendwie 5% der Leute sterben. Und natürlich kann man dann, wenn man sich mit dem Arzt unterhält, dann hat man noch deutlich mehr Kontext dabei, man sieht irgendwie, wie der so drauf ist, man kennt den. Aber wenn man das einfach im Labor einem so vorsetzt, und wie diese beiden Sätze, dann gibt es natürlich schon eine Verzerrung in dem, was dann die Leute sich aussuchen würden an der Operation. Also dass Psychologen so ein grundsätzliches Problem haben, so ein hochkomplexes System, wie einen Menschen zu analysieren, indem sie einfach einzelne Verhaltensweisen im Labor sezieren wollen, funktioniert genauso schlecht, wie sich ein Vogelflügel angucken.
Vorbei man der Verhaltenspsychologie, also dafür muss man eine Lanze brechen.
Ich glaube, es ist die einzige psychologische Therapieform, die überhaupt Therapie-Erfolge vorzuweisen hat.
Aber wir reden ja gar nicht über Therapie. Verhaltenstherapie und Perhapism sind verschiedene Dinge, hat nichts mit dazu zu tun. Es gibt sozusagen einen therapeutischen Flügel der Psychologie, der hilft den Menschen. Und es gibt einen wissenschaftlichen Flügel der Psychologie, der versucht, Sachen rauszukriegen. Und die beiden haben erstaunlich wenig miteinander zu tun.
Soweit bin ich nie gekommen, das rauszufinden.
Ich dachte immer, das wäre...
Das war das einzige Spannende, was ich mir da angehört habe. Deswegen habe ich mich da in diese Psychologie reingesetzt.
Ich habe irgendwann Walden Two gelesen und dachte, ach du Scheiße.
Ich finde es interessant, dass viel von der richtig tollen Psychologie ist in Romanen drin. Wenn man Kundera liest oder Dostoevsky, das sind echte Psychologen. Die haben sich ganz große Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie funktionieren Menschen, wie funktioniert menschliche Motivation, auf welchen Schichten, wie funktioniert die Logik von Menschen, wie hängt das alles zusammen. Darüber haben die aber keine Bücher geschrieben, sondern die Bücher geschrieben, die diese Wissen benutzen. Es steckt da aber alles drin. Also doch noch Dostoevsky.
Haben wir den Paul eigentlich noch an der Leitung?
Der Paul ist immer noch da, der nimmt sich schon das Wort, wenn er will.
Ja, fällt mir gerade noch bei Therapie ein, wenn ihr gerade das noch ansprecht. Und zwar war das ganz interessant. Ich hab mal vor nicht allzu langer Zeit einen Zeitungsartikel noch gelesen. Und zwar hatten die in Japan einen Erziehungsroboter konstruiert, der eigentlich ganz primitiv nur Stoff rüber gebracht hat, aber auf eine unglaublich geduldige und verständnisvolle Art und Weise. Es war an der Grundschule wohl gemacht worden. Und das Faszinierende daran war, jetzt auch psychologisches Experiment, dass die Kinder diesen Roboter, oder es war wohl irgendwie auch mit ansprechender Hülle, als hatten sie sich auch bemüht, den halbwegs menschenähnlich darzustellen.
Hello Kitty. Das ist aber genau geschummelt. Damit hast du ja den Touring-Test eigentlich beschummelt, indem du einfach schon mal was hinsetzt, dem dann viel eher eine, ja, es könnte ein Mensch sein. Vielleicht bewegt sie das Gesicht noch. Vielleicht verhält er sich so ein bisschen, guckt manchmal wie blinzelt und so. Hast du denn ja schon die Wahrnehmung, was da einem da wohl gegenüber steht, in eine Richtung unfair verschoben gegenüber, vielleicht einem intelligenteren System, was...
Das mag ja auch sein, aber der Clou an der Sache war eigentlich, dass es dabei primär darum ging, dass die Kinder, die jetzt bei diesem System, nennen wir es mal Systemunterricht hatten, diesem Roboter eine unglaubliche Sympathie entgegengebracht haben, weil er sozusagen so verständnisvoll war. Und eigentlich gar nicht so. Das war genau dieses Ding, was du auch erzählt hattest, mit dem Androiden hier von ETR. Hoffmann, der im Prinzip mit einer Äußerung, mit einer Wortäußerung ein Gefühl von Verständnis hervorgerufen hat. Und bei diesem Lernexperiment war das eben auch vorhanden. Und da hat sich herausgestellt, dass die Kinder bei diesem Roboter-Lehrer eigentlich unglaublich gut gelernt haben.
Na, wir werden diese Forschung auch brauchen, weil wenn wir demnächst wirklich alle alt sind, dann muss uns irgendjemand dadurch die Gegendkarren den Arsch abwischen und da wollen wir dann auch nicht, dass es irgendein Terminator-Style-Roboter ist, mit dem wir uns da nicht... Wär schon schöner, wenn er irgendwie setzt sich da hin und da hält sich mit uns noch, bis wir dann...
Du hast so einen schwarzen Eckerkacker.
Ach nee, lassen Sie mal. Aber ja, es ist ein wichtiger Punkt, der Sozialisierung ist natürlich auch, wie man selbst wahrgenommen wird und wie Menschen auf einen reagieren und wie Menschen auf Physikonomie, auf Sprache, auf Formen von Interaktionen reagieren. Und daran normiert man sich ja auch selber. Also es ist ja auch wie Kinder großgezogen werden, indem sie sehen, die Eltern freuen sich gerade über das, was ich tue. Na gut, am Anfang ist es wahrscheinlich egal. Aber dann, je älter man wird, desto mehr guckt man schon, dass man sich dort in den sozialen Normen selber, ja, eigentlich sein Gehirn dann, ja, rund schleift an den kantigen Stellen. Ob das jetzt gut ist oder nicht, keine Ahnung. Aber das ist ja so klassische Erziehung, die dann am Ende dann irgendwie so einen Interaktionspartner jetzt aus unserer wissenschaftlichen Betrachtung macht, der dann irgendwie so als intelligent durchgeht.
Die Frage, die ich mir bei solchen Sachen immer stelle, ist eigentlich, was für eine Konsequenz hätte, wenn jetzt Systeme tatsächlich eine selbstlernende und selbstbegreifende Fähigkeit erreichen würden, irgendwie Stufe erreichen würden, weil die würden ja dann irgendwann auch anfangen, ihr, ich nenne es jetzt mal ganz pathetisch sein, ihr Sein zu hinterfragen.
Eigene wahnsinnige Pläne schmücken.
Ja, das wäre dieses klassische Science-Fiction-Horror-Scenario eigentlich.
Es gibt sogar Institute dazu, die sich auf die Fahnen geschrieben haben, genau das zu verhindern, weil sie darin die größte Gefahr für die Menschheit sehen. Dieses Phänomen nennt sich Singularity. Was da passiert ist, wir bauen Computer, die so intelligent sind, dass sie selber intelligente Computer bauen können. Dann könnten die ja Computer bauen, die noch intelligenter sind. Und egal, was wir in die erste Generation von Computer reingebaut haben, was in der dritten und vierten Generation passiert, können wir nicht vorhersehen. Und diese zweite und dritte und vierte Generationen stehen jedes Mal schneller und besser und sind irgendwann so toll, dass sie diesen ganzen Planeten übernehmen. Und die Menschheit verhält sich zu denen so wie Ameisen zu uns. Und das bedeutet, ab und zu sind sie halt im Weg, wenn man eine neue Straße baut.
Ich schreib in jeder meiner Software immer als oberste Zeile Am I a part of Skynet? Then exit. Immer gleich.
Das bedeutet, dass deine Software nicht drin sein wird, Erdgeist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so clever ist.
Gerade wo deine Software doch lauter Hintertüren hat.
Ist denn diese Gefahr eigentlich real? Oder ist die noch in weiter Zukunft?
Jede Gefahr ist immer real.
Gefahr! Wo ich auch erst vorhin zu befragt wurde, ist ja, wenn du ein zentrales Skynet-System hast, was dort mit einem Plan vorgeht, den du nicht durchsteigst. Oder wenn du lauter Agenten hast, die sich einzeln alle vielleicht noch nach einem simplen Plan verhalten, aber deren Gesamtkomplexität du durch die Interaktion nicht mehr verstehst, weil das Chaos im System einfach zu groß geworden ist, hast du plötzlich auch ein System, mit dem du konfrontiert bist, wo du nicht mal die Möglichkeit hast zu begreifen, ob deine Intelligenz dahinter steckt, weil sie sich irgendwie im Touring-Test, wenn da eine Drohnenarme auf dich zukommt, die setzt sich nicht geduldig mit dir hin und macht den Touring-Test, sondern...
Naja, woher willst du wissen, dass es intelligent ist?
Oder dass es nicht intelligent ist, genau.
Ich glaube, Ranka Yogeshwar hat mal was Schönes erzählt.
Er würde einfach, ich sag schnell, Hüllkurven nehmen, also einfach Audio-Hüllkurven von einer blubbernden Tomatensuppe und Hüllkurven von irgendwie Musik.
Und würde sagen, so, und jetzt unterscheiden bitte mal, sag mir mal, welches davon ist intelligent?
So, welches Teil von diesen?
Irgendwie so was, da geht es halt um SETI halt.
Das fand ich irgendwie ganz witzig. Woran kann ich erkennen, also was ist der Unterschied zwischen einer blubbernden, kochenden Tomatensuppe jetzt in so einem Spektrogramm und irgendwie einer intelligenten Botschaft?
Na, da gab es aber Ansätze zu versuchen, das zu komprimieren und dann schauen, ob sie es komprimieren lässt. Wenn sie es nicht komprimieren lässt, dann ist ziemlich viel Zufall dabei.
Oder Information? Struktur?
Na, wenn sie es nicht komprimieren lässt, dann ist Zufall dabei. Nein. Wenn Struktur dabei ist, dann lässt es sich gut komprimieren.
Wenn Redundanz drin ist?
Ja, Struktur der Redundanz. Shannon hat ja versucht zu beschreiben, er hat ja diese Signalverarbeitungstheorie dort fast eigenhändig aus dem Boden gestampft. Da hat er gesagt, dass eine der gängigen Ansätze ist, einfach die Redundanz drin zu erkennen. Und das ist ja genau, was ein guter Kompressionsalgorithmus macht. Und wenn sich da so Dinge weg komprimieren lassen, dann ist da kein Zufall drin, sondern irgendeine Art von Struktur.
Es gibt ja auch so eine Sicht des Intelligenz-Datenkompressions. Lasst uns gleich dazu zurückkommen. Aber Carl hat ja eine Frage gestellt. Er wollte wissen, ob wir heute noch ein Apfelbäumchen pflanzen sollen oder ob es sich nicht mehr lohnt. Die Antwort würde ich wahrscheinlich ungefähr so geben, so ähnlich wie mit den Meteoreinschlägen oder so. Man weiß es nicht. Weil wir haben zu wenig Daten. Das ist bis jetzt noch nicht passiert. Zumindest nicht, dass wir es wüssten. Und deswegen kann man überhaupt keine seriöse Auskunft darüber geben, aus meiner Sicht nach, weil die Baseline fehlt, wie wahrscheinlich das ist. Das heißt, jeden, den man fragt, der kann eigentlich nur ein Bauchgefühl geben. Bei den Meteoreinschlägen ist es halt auch so. Wir haben jetzt gerade letztes Jahr einen entdeckt, der möglicherweise nächstes Jahr auf dem Mars aufprallt und 50 Kilometer Durchmesser hat. Wir könnten also auch diesen Monat einen entdecken, der über nächstes Jahr hier einschlägt. Und dann ist es Essenze. Es ist total schwer. Wie groß ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das passiert? Man kann allgemeine Zahlen geben, aber die nutzen einem nicht allzu viel.
Es macht aber auch nicht viel Unterschied. Genauso kann bei dir in der Arterie dort übermorgen ein großer Klumpen an einer falschen Stelle hängen bleiben.
Aber dann bist du und ich ja immer noch da, vermutlich.
Ja, schon, aber ihnen kann es egal sein.
Es gibt Philosophen, die sind da anderer Meinung.
Und Altruisten sind ja Menschen, die an deinem Fort bestehen. Auch noch Interesse am Erdgeist.
Erdgeist, das sind die, die wir Schwachsinnige nennen.
Es gibt noch eine andere Perspektive, und nämlich die, dass das schon lange passiert ist.
Das ist dann die Matrix-Theorie, oder wie?
Nee, viel harmloser. Das Ding ist, es muss ja nicht unbedingt so sein, dass es irgendeine Selizium-basierte KI ist oder so, sondern worum es eigentlich dabei geht, ist, dass es ein nicht-menschlicher Agent ist. Also ein Ding, das handelt, das ein Gedächtnis hat, das eigene Ziele und Absichten hat, und die vertritt und dabei nicht-menschliche Ziele hat und mächtiger ist als Menschen.
Die NATO?
Zum Beispiel. Tatsächlich jede Organisation. Organisationen borgen sich menschliche Intelligenz. Die könnten sich genauso gut KI borgen. Und machen das auch an manchen Stellen, zum Beispiel Banken und so weiter. Und auch Firmen nehmen KI als Entscheidungshilfe. Aber Firmen und so weiter sind mächtiger als Menschen. Der neue Chef von der Deutschen Bank ist komischerweise wieder nicht der Ströbele geworden. Das liegt aber nicht daran, dass der Ströbele nicht zur Verfügung standen hätte, sondern dass der die Rolle nicht hätte ausfüllen können, die die Deutsche Bank vorgesehen hat, für den, von dem sie sich Intelligenz borgt. Aber im Grunde genommen hat die Deutsche Bank als Organisation eine innen wohrende Logik. Und das ist ein Agent, der tut Dinge, die einzelne Leute, zum Beispiel der Sprecher der Deutschen Bank, vielleicht gar nicht richtig finden. Und trotzdem wird der Sprecher der Deutschen Bank sagen, was die Bank, die die Schäden an ihm zieht, von ihm hören will. Sonst kriegt er den Job nicht.
Dadurch hast du auch immer das Problem, dass du keine moralische Instanz da drin hast, bzw. die Moral dieser Instanz vielleicht gar nicht erkennst, weil sie größer ist als du selbst.
Ist ja einfach ein nichtmenschlicher Agent.
Transzendente Moral.
Es ist aber wichtig, darauf hinzuweisen, weil ja in den Veranigten bestarten dort auch diese Gerichtsurteile, wo sie gesagt haben, Corporations are people. Ja, es ist vielleicht eine Intelligenz, irgendwie ein Organismus, aber er ist nicht sehr menschlich. Er ist eigentlich ein Soziopath. Und auf viele von Dingen bescheiden hat, Höflichkeit darauf zu achten, was man morgen noch über ihn denkt, hat so ein Organismus dann nicht von sich aus mit? Na ja, schon.
Es emergiert gerade Corporate Social Responsibility. Also der Organismus lernt gerade, dass es für sein Fortbestehen sinnvoller sein kann.
Man nennt es Marketing. Es würde aber nicht drauf reinfallen. Das Problem ist nämlich Corporate Social Responsibility hin oder her. Das ist PR, das ist klar. Ein Großteil der Kommentare, die ich im Augenblick zu vielen Themen sehe, werden höchstwahrscheinlich von Firmen generiert im Internet, um bestimmte Public Responses zu erzeugen und zu simulieren. Ich finde das krass, wenn unsere Politiker sich treffen auf Klimakonferenzen und jeder einzelne Politiker möchte gerne ein Ziel erreichen, aber sie können es alle nicht, weil ihre jeweiligen Organisationen das verhindern.
Also würdet ihr sagen, dass im Prinzip die Firmen bzw. Lobbies der einzelnen Branchen im Prinzip eine Art Schwarmintelligenz sind, die aber asozial gegenüber anderen Intelligenzen handelt?
Gegenüber Menschen auf jeden Fall.
Gegenüber Menschen auf jeden Fall, ok.
Na klar, warum sollten Firmen sich sozial gegenüber Menschen verhalten, außer es bringt ihnen Vorteile bezogen auf die Baseline? Weil die Fitnessfunktion von Unternehmen ist natürlich letztendlich der Shareholder Value. Und es gibt ein Feedback dazu zum Wohlergehen der Menschheit, aber das ist relativ schwach. Das heißt, es ist völlig ok, wenn wir zum Beispiel jetzt alle Kohlenwasserstoffe, die wir in die Hand kriegen können, verbrennen, weil es ökonomisch Sinn macht, auch wenn es dazu führt, dass der Planet sich um 5 Grad erwärmt oder mehr. Und das hier aussieht wie bei Mad Max.
Aus evolutionärer Sicht eigentlich Schwachsinn.
Ja, aber das ist möglicherweise wie so ein Krebs. Evolution greift ja immer erst ab der nächsten Generation.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und wenn es keine gibt?
Das ist Ende.
Ja, bitte, bitte. Was? Ja, bitte, bitte, hat Spaß gemacht.
Gleichzeit.
Schmein Gott.
Eine Knappe haben wir noch.
Hier ist nämlich Chaosradio 187 mit Erdgeist und Joscha und ich bin Holger.
Und lade euch natürlich ein auch anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110, wie der Paul das eben gemacht hat.
Vielleicht habt ihr auch noch die ein oder andere kluge oder doofe Frage, die wir hier beantworten können. Können wir noch mal kurz zurück zu den BH-Vioristen gehen?
Der BH-Viorismus sagt, alles, was wir tun, ist eigentlich Verhalten.
Das ist erlernt und wir spulen da im Grunde ja irgendwie ein Programm ab, das man auch ohne weiteres umprogrammieren kann.
Haben die, haben die Recht oder haben die Unrecht?
Das Problem ist, dass die davon ausgehen, dass das Programm daraus besteht, dass es Reize mit Reaktionen wäscht. Und als Informatiker würde ich sagen, das funktioniert nicht. Ich brauche Hidden States, ich brauche inneren Struktur, die innere Zustände abbildet. Ich muss sowas wie ein Weltmodell zum Beispiel haben. Ich kann nicht einfach nur Reize der Welt aufnehmen und auf diese Reize direkt reagieren. Ich muss also bestimmte Konstruktionseinheiten annehmen, wenn ich das zum Funktionieren bringen will. Und das ist die Perspektive, die wir als Informatiker haben. Was sind die Funktionen, die wir einbauen müssen um so ein System, damit es überhaupt geht? Und da gucken die Psychologen gar nicht so sehr drauf, sondern die haben ja schon funktionierende Systeme vor sich oder Systeme mit charakteristischen Defekten. Die sind so ein bisschen wie ein Automechaniker, der sich weigert, unter die Haube zu gucken. Und der kann das auch gar nicht, weil damals gab es die Werkzeuge dafür nicht, um die Haube aufzumachen und zu verstehen, was darunter stattfindet. Und stattdessen, um rauszukriegen, was mit dem Auto nicht funktioniert, baut er so eine Art Hindernisparcours auf. Und da lässt er das Auto im Kreis fahren. Und dabei horcht er, was es für Geräusche macht und was für Geschwindigkeiten das hat und so. Und zum Schluss mixt er ein bestimmtes Additiv und gießt das in den Tank und hofft, dass das hilft. Und das ist im Prinzip das, was der Psychologe tun kann. Manchmal geht es gut.
Ich habe auch mal so einen Geschirrspülmaschinenreparierer, der genau das gemacht hat. Der kam zu mir nach Hause, hat gesagt, er mach mal an, wie aufschrauben ist eh nicht. Dann hat er wie so ein Indianer auf dem Fußboden auch gesessen, sich das angehört, wie es rumpelt und meinte, ah, ich hör schon.
Okay, das hat er aber, weil er es irgendwann in seinem Leben schon mal aufgeschraubt hat.
Ja, glaub schon.
Mach dir mal eine schöne Geschichte kaputt.
Ja, du hast doch eben auch hier.
Ja, also was wir machen wollen, wir wollen erst mal so ein primitives, mögliches Auto bauen, so einfach wie möglich. Und dann, wenn wir das hingekriegt haben, dann können wir mal gucken, wie funktionieren den Menschen. Wo finden wir denn da den Vergaser sozusagen und die Gangschaltung? Oder machen Menschen das ganz anders?
Was macht denn dieses primitive Auto denn?
Im Kreisfahren.
Ja, also was heißt das?
Was heißt das übersetzt?
Ein Bein kürzer als das andere. Na, das bedeutet zum Beispiel, dass es in der Lage ist, wenn man ihm zum Beispiel einen Körper gibt, sich dessen zu bedienen, so ähnlich wie ein Mensch das tut, vielleicht nicht ganz so geschickt, aber überhaupt.
Braucht das denn den Körper überhaupt?
Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, dass es auch in World of Warcraft ganz glücklich leben könnte, wenn diese Welt interessant genug ist. Also sagen wir vielleicht Minecraft, weil Minecraft ist schlau genug, dass man da drin Computer bauen kann. Aber das ist eine Sache, das müssen wir empirisch rauskriegen.
Vielleicht möchte es ja auch interagieren mit der stofflichen Reaktion.
Das ist, was ich ja vorhin meinte, dass ein Kind ja auch auf das emotionale Feedback, auf seine eigene physikonomische Gymnastik dort angewiesen ist, schaut, welche Aktionen irgendwie positives Feedback hervorrufen. Die Frage ist, ab wann man das dem einfach so hinmodellieren kann, weil wenn das Ziel unserer Forschung am Ende ist, irgendwas, was sich dann schon wie ein Mensch, wie ein Ping-Pong Ball, wie ein Gesprächspartner funktioniert, dann will man von ihm ja auch vielleicht bestimmte emotionale Interaktionen, die man so erwartet in der Kommunikation mit einem Menschen. Vielleicht muss man ihm das dann irgendwie noch als Add-on da am Ende mit beibringen, dass er sich nicht komplett wie ein gefühlloser Soziopath da herbewegt.
Egal, was du ihm sagst, der sagt, ne.
Ja, bloß ich, da kenn ich auch so Leute. Und da waren die Behaviouristen, sind ja dann, weißt du, du kannst ja dieses Programm da verändern, in dem die ihm einfach große Mengen Bonnen tüte und dann ist irgendwie so danach nicht mehr viel über und dann kreieren wir auch.
Naja, aber wir sehen ja, dass es mentale Repräsentationen gibt. Wir, nicht nur introspektiv, sondern wir operieren mit diesen Dingern. Es ist total schwer, sich eine Welt vorzustellen, in der es keine mentalen Repräsentationen gibt, also Dinge, die in unserem Geist stattfinden. Ich stelle mir das im Grunde genommen so vor, dass in unserer Systemgrenze, also der auch wie immer gearteten Grenze zwischen uns und unserer Umwelt, wir können zum Beispiel sagen, das könnte unsere Netzhaut sein, oder das könnte unsere Körperoberfläche sein, oder wir könnten sagen, es ist unser soziales Umfeld oder sowas, dass wir diese Grenze, die nehmen wir und überlegen, da kommt Information rein. Diese Information, das sind einfach Muster, das sind wahrnehmbare Unterschiede. Die Definition von Information ist im Grunde genommen wahrnehmbare Unterschiede. Und Bits, ein Bit ist die Maßeinheit für wahrnehmbaren Unterschiede. Und in diesen uns aufeinander einprasselnden Bits, die da über unsere Systemgrenze kommen, da findet unser Nervensystem eine Ordnung. Und auf der untersten Ebene dieser Ordnung stehen Perzepte, das sind so Regelmäßigkeiten der perceptuellen Wahrnehmung, zum Beispiel so was wie Kontraste, Konturen und irgendwelche Blobs und so. Und auf einer höheren Ebene setzt unser Nervensystem die zusammen, das kodiert die in Objekte zum Beispiel und Situationen und Prozesse. Und dann abstrahiert es diese Objekte in Klassen. Zum Beispiel wird dann aus diesem fälligen Ding mit dieser samtlichen Urfläche irgendwann so eine Katze. Und die Katze, die ist ein spezieller Fall von Tier, vielleicht von Haustier. Und irgendwann fangen wir an, die Haustiere stärker zu unterteilen, merken, dass manche Katzen bellen und manche Katzen miauen. Und dann unterteilen wir die Katzen in Katzen und Hunde. Und da auf die Art und Weise kriegen wir immer reichhaltigere Bilder von der Welt. Und die werden auch stark davon inspiriert, was andere Leute uns für Kategorien vorschlagen. Dann fangen wir vielleicht aktiv an, nach Unterschieden zwischen Katzen und Hunden zu suchen und so fort.
Das ist ein sehr spannender Punkt, der irgendwie wahrscheinlich auch nie aufhört. Weil eigentlich ja so eine Intelligenz immer in der Interaktion mit anderen Leuten auch existiert. Ich sammle selber nicht alles Wissen. Ich weiß nicht immer, wen ich fragen muss. Oder ich weiß vielleicht im Zweifel, wo ich nachlesen muss. Aber ich weiß auch, wenn ich bestimmte Stimuli brauche, auf eine nicht so einfach nur als Wissen nachzulesende Art und Weise, dann weiß ich auch, in wen ich mich da in diesem sozialen Kontext wenden muss. Und das ist sowieso vielleicht ein Ding, wenn Joscha meint, er braucht irgendjemanden, mit dem er Ping-Pong spielen kann, dann musst du wahrscheinlich erst diesem System auch mit diesem Ping-Pong geliefert haben, ihn mit Dingen überraschen, ihn dahin konditionieren. Was wahrscheinlich auch so ein Problem ist. Weil die Anzahl der Menschen, die so Computersysteme trainieren könnten, sind dann auch nur begrenzt verfügbar.
Du müsstest ja auch erst mal wissen, was das Computersystem überhaupt möchte.
Das kann ich ihm ja einbauen.
Stimmt, ich war schon bei autonomem... Was treibt dich denn immer so groß an? Das ist auch nur die Basics. Shelter und Fortpflanzen, ein bisschen was essen.
Ne, noch mehr. Ich glaube, du hast ja nicht nur physiologische Triebe, sondern auf der gleichen Ebene, genauso wichtig soziale und kognitive Triebe.
Weinst du, das ist so basales oder ist es antrainiert?
Ne, ich glaube, dass es nicht antrainiert ist. Es ist ja auch so, dass es deswegen interpersonale Varianzen gibt. Also ich kann ja gucken, dass es Persönlichkeitsunterschiede gibt, die auch bei den Big Five, also Offenheit und Freundlichkeit und neurotische Stabilität und diese Grundparameter, die man in der Psychologie einigermaßen bestimmen kann, gibt es, die sind zur Hälfte erblich. Das bedeutet, die sind eingestellt. Da müssen Mechanismen dahinter stehen. Und das sind, glaube ich, motivationale Mechanismen. Zum Beispiel sind Soziopathen, glaube ich, Leute, die einfach keinen sozialen Trieb haben. Das bedeutet, die kriegen keinen Lustsignal aus der Befriedigung von sozialen Trieben. Wenn die der Oma über die Straße helfen, erzeugt das bei denen keinen Lustsignal. Bei dir und mir erzeugt es aber eins. Wir fühlen uns spontan besser. Es gibt einen kleinen Kick. Und dieser kleine Kick ist ein positives Reinforcementsignal. Und die Evolution hat das in uns reingebaut. Das hat einen ganz knallharten evolutionären Nutzen. Du redest gerade den Behaviouristen nach dem Mund. Wenn ich den Behaviouristen, dann nicht den Soziobiologen.
Aber wobei, das liest du sich auch behaviouristisch verargumentieren.
Was ich im Unterschied zu den Behaviouristen meine, ist, dass ich mentale Zustände untersuchen kann. Ich kann darüber reden, was im Geist vorgeht. Ich muss nicht nur von Reiz und Reaktion reden. Das ist so der Unterschied. Ich will das nachbauen.
Kommen wir doch mal zum Nachbauen. Wie sieht es denn mit Nachbauten aus?
Was gibt es denn da Interessantes, abgesehen von Eliza und dem Schachtürken? Schachtürken. Schachtürke war ja so der erst dann so im Orakel angelehnte Maschine, die es so vorgetäuscht hat, man würde gegen einen Computerschach spielen. Und der war dann, um noch ein wenig orientalischen Charme damit rein zu tun, es ein bisschen geheimnisvoller zu machen, war er halt wie ein Türke verkleidet, oder was damals das Bild eines Türkens gewesen ist.
Computer hießen damals Roboter oder noch anders?
Roboter? Nee, das war irgendwie erst später. Asimov hat das doch erfunden in einem von seinem Roman?
Nee, nicht Asimov, das war... Nein.
Auch nicht?
Nein, der Tscheche war es.
Das ist doch gar nicht so alt mit den Robotern.
Nee, das Wort kommt von Roboter, von Arbeit im Slawischen. Und das war so eine Oper, die er geschrieben hat, Rostoms Universal Robots, so ein Androiden, die rumlaufen sollten. Aber dieses Konzept des Androiden, also des Maschinenmenschen, das gibt es schon seit der Antike. Wir hätten noch einen Anrufer mit einer Frage.
Namens Alex. Hallo, Alex. Du hast eine Frage, ne?
Ja. Also erst mal muss ich sagen, ich muss Fragen haben, denn ich kann nicht dazu sagen, weil das eine absolut abgefahrene Sendung mit dir gerade macht.
Ja, ich bin auch sehr fasziniert.
Absolut abgefahren. Also das mit den Organisationen, dass man da so denken kann mit den Filmen, ja, es ist so und es ist so. Deswegen kann ich einfach nur fragen, rein zu sagen, ja, ich muss das mal so reinschmeißen, sonst vergess ich nämlich alles, was ich sagen wollte. Und zwar, ich bin Papa von zwei Töchtern und hab mich ganz oft gefragt, wie das ist mit den Menschen oder mit den Kindern, wie die erzogen werden, ob das nur Umweltanflüsse sind oder nicht, oder ob sie als leeres Blatt Papier zur Welt kommen. Ich bin zum Schluss gekommen, dass sie als leeres Blatt Papier oder als weißes Blatt Papier zur Welt kommen. Allerdings ist die Struktur des Papiers immer unterschiedlich.
Das wäre die erste Welt. Also gleichsam handgeschöpft sozusagen.
Handgeschöpft oder maschinenglatt, strukturiert, ein bisschen gräulich, angegraut, wie auch immer. Die Struktur ist einfach unterschiedlich und das Papier kann man dann beschreiben mit Umwelteinflüssen. Erstens natürlich die Eltern, dann kommen alle nach und nach. Dann die zweite Anmerkung wäre, was hat das Ganze, diese künstliche Indigenz oder die Nachahmung des Lebens, zurzeit noch, mit der Fantasie des Menschen zu tun. Natürlich muss man auch wieder die Fantasie aus einer dröselnden Basis-Fantasie definieren. Und das Dritte, was ich dazu sagen wollte, ist, wenn man Gefühle erlebt, die du vorhin drüber gesprochen hast, kann man nicht die künstliche Illigenz so bauen, dass er auf bestimmte Reize mit einem bestimmten Programm reagiert. Das heißt z.B. man ist eingegeben, wenn er etwas mit blauen Augen sieht, was eine gewisse Nuance an Geruch hat und einen gewissen Tonfall, dass er dann sich zurück erinnert oder dass er dann ein Programm drin hat, dass er bei diesen Parametern sagen muss, ich liebe dich, ich finde dich gut. Ist das nicht der Ansatz, das so zu machen oder die Gefühle der Menschen entstehen noch? Das sind auch ganz viele zusammen gemixste Sachen.
Das, was du da erzählst, habe ich zwar in der Disco schon öfter gesehen, aber es macht mir ein bisschen Angst. Also wenn du wie so ein einfaches Beuteschema hast, hast du irgendwie blaue Augen und...
Nein, das ist ja nicht der geile Gönner. Ganz viele andere Parameter dazu. Oder jeder, den man erreichen will. Zu einer Liebe gehören ganz viele andere Parallele. Für diesen blauen Augen, das ist ja nur die Nacht. Aber so ein liebes Empfinden gönnen ja noch ganz viele andere. Aber ist das nicht der Ansatz, so was zu machen, nachzueinzünden, so eine Gefühle?
Na, wenn du irgendwie in der Historie siehst, wie sich irgendwie die Schönheitsideale von Menschen da über die Jahrhunderte verändert haben, dann glaube ich, das ist ganz einfach deutlich, dass solche Präferenzen in der Natur nicht vorgegeben sind, sondern anerzogen sind.
Da wäre ich total vorsichtig. Also zum Beispiel hat früher in meinem Weltbild die Vorstellung, dass wir alle bisexuell sind, super gut reingepasst. Dann habe ich praktisch auf die harte Tour lernen müssen, dass das nicht stimmt. Ich komme ja aus so einer Familie, wo meine Mutter eigentlich total dankbar gewesen wäre, wenn ich früh gewesen wäre. Aber das funktionierte irgendwie nicht.
Nein, also eine Schönheitsideale und eine sexuelle Präferenz im Geschlecht sind noch zwei unterschiedliche Dinge. Das ist wie damals eher die wohlgenähte Fahne.
Das ist sicherlich adaptiv.
Ich meine jetzt auch nicht, das ist nicht das Schönheitsideal. Eine gewisse Ausstrahlung muss ja vorhanden sein.
Das was du meinst, ist eher die Adaption, dass wir nämlich lernen, diesen Reiz mit diesem Gefühl zu verknüpfen.
Richtig, weil es ist ja so schon, dass mir zum Beispiel, mir persönlich, würde es schwerfallen, wenn wir... Ich rebe vielstens auf das Schönheitsideal, weil wir jetzt gerade sind. Es gehören noch ganz, ganz, ganz viele andere Parameter dazu. Aber als ersten Kontaktaufnahme, dass ich überhaupt mein Reiz wahr wird und ich Liebe empfinden könnte, dass ich bereit werde, diese Liebe zu finden könnte, es ist jetzt schwer, wenn eine grau, am ganzen Körper behaarte Frau auf mich zukommen würde.
Heutzutage triffst du die doch eh im Internet. Da siehst du das doch erst, nachdem du schon ihr Verscheiden bist.
Ja, du weißt doch, was ich meine, weißt du? Und da gehören schon gewisse Parameter dazu, dass ich erstmal bereit bin, sowas zu empfangen. Und dann muss sie natürlich auch das bestätigen, was ich mir vorstelle, also sie muss natürlich dann klug daherreden und auch spaßig sein und all sowas, bis ich dann irgendwann... Die Liebe, na die ist schon sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr...
Liebe ist ja auch schon eine sehr komplexe...
Das ist mir jetzt aber glaube ich ein bisschen zu platt, also schulde, aber das dann da so drauf zurückzuführen, dass du dann wie so Schlüsselreize ankonditionierst einfach auf die Weile und dann einfach schon meins verliebt zu sein, das ist nicht...
Nein, ich meine nicht, dass das Schlüsselreize... Aber irgendwas muss ich doch auslösen, wenn du hier dafür verliebt bist.
Ja, ja, das ist biochemische Prozesse, die ganz nützlich sind, um die Kinder dann irgendwie groß werden zu lassen gemeinsam, nachdem man irgendwie einfach nur dort wie Verkehr hatte. Genau, danach muss aber irgendwie noch ein Kit dazu kommen, der dazu führt, dass die Kinder großziehen. Aber das ist ja auch so ein biologisches Konstrukt, was ganz nützlich ist, weil meistens ist es nach sieben Jahren vorbei. Ja, da spreche ich ja gerade von. Das ist einfach auch so Hormonmix, der da irgendwie so sieht, ganz praktisch aus. So die Konturen da sehen so aus, als ob das Kind, was da rauskommt, ganz praktisch ist oder so und dann...
Ich finde diesen Ansatz gar nicht so schlecht. Ich finde es ganz gut, dass man losgeht und erstmal sagt, okay, wie weit kommen wir denn damit? Zum Beispiel, das, was du gerade vorgeschlagen hast, finde ich gar nicht so doof. Zu sagen, wir brauchen irgendwie einen Prozess, mit dem wir lernen, Sachen zusammenzufassen. Zum Beispiel, das ist eine Frau und das ist eine Frau, die aufgeladen ist mit bestimmten Erwartungen für mich. Also, wie komme ich denn dahin, dass ich überhaupt so ein Konzept von der Frau bilde aufgrund von bestimmten Merkmalen, die ich wahrnehme, zum Beispiel, dass sie sich so und so bewegt, dass sie so und so aussieht. Was bringt mich denn überhaupt dazu, die als Frau zu klassifizieren oder sogar als begehrenswerte Frau? Und dann eine ganz andere Frage, was ist denn dieses Gefühl eigentlich? Was wird dann da hervorgerufen? Ich würde schon versuchen, zu überlegen, was sind die Zutaten von all diesen Sachen? Ich würde versuchen, die zusammenzubauen. Ich würde dann feststellen, dass es nicht funktioniert. Und dann habe ich was gelernt.
Ich versuche mir das gerade wieder wissenschaftlich anzusehen, weil wir reden ja davon, dass wir das künstlich nachbauen wollen. Eigentlich wäre dann dieses echt fieses Experiment da mal zu gucken, ob wann man sich dann ernsthaft an diese eine KI, die da wächst, wie verliebt. Und dann hast du wieder eine Versuchsperson, die hier jetzt nicht abschalten. Ist schon hart, oder? Und am Ende ist dann auch vielleicht der Drang, das physisch auszuleben, dann auch nicht so richtig möglich. Weil dann müsstest du dann wieder hinter deine KI dann wieder plötzlich einen Roboter bauen, der dann da, obwohl da gibt's Puppen.
Wir hatten ja mal so eine Diskussion, da meinte ein Student, ich könnte mich doch nie in Roboter verlieben. Und dann meinte jemand das, naja, kommt drauf an, ob sie gut aussieht.
Also ich finde dieses Thema absolut abgefahren, wirklich. Und weil ich glaube schon, dass wir da schon sehr, ich hab da letztens auch irgendwas gesehen, was mich auch zum Teil vermockt hat, dass da irgendwer mit Gedanken im Rollstuhl gelenkt hat. Das ist echt abgefahren. Aber das kann man denke ich noch ableiten von den Prozessen, elektrochemischen Prozessen, die mir hin stattfinden, die man dann durch ganz, ganz sensible Wellenerde auch so ein Ding auf dem Kopf ableiten kann.
Diese bildgebenden Verfahren sind da jetzt schon so weit, dass man auch Koma-Patienten darauf konditionieren kann, in eine bestimmte Richtung zu denken, in andere Richtung, und dann wie ja nein Fragen zu beantworten, wenn da wenig Restkognitive.
Es ist Wahnsinn, was für Vortritte man macht, und wie schnell vor allen Dingen das geht. Also wirklich abgefahren. Deswegen bin ich auch gerade total fasziniert von dieser Sendung. Und muss da einfach irgendwas, nicht irgendwas, aber das dazu sagen, weil das auch mich wirklich völlig fasziniert. Und es ist schön auch wahrgenommen zu werden. Und da muss ich auch wahnsinnig. Also da bin ich total fasziniert, dass wir auch in der Welt leben und dass ich auch so etwas erleben darf, muss ich sagen.
Was ich total interessant finde, ist, dass deine Töchter dich so reingelegt haben, dass die als tabula rasa auf die Welt kamen. Ich wohne da auch im Prenzlauer Berg, wo es ganz schlimm ist, so richtig am Helmholtzplatz, so volle Kanne, lauter kleine Kinder, alle ungefähr gleich alt. Die werden auch alle gleichzeitig in die Pubertät kommen und dann sitze ich in Tempelhof und lach dich aus. Genau, und die werden dann auch alle gleichzeitig wegziehen. Danach wird es da aussehen wie heute in Charlottenburg oder in Tempelhof. Wülmersdorf. Die wir nach der Wende hingezogen sind und jetzt alle noch schnell ihre Kinder kriegen, bevor es aus ist. Naja, ich habe jetzt bei meinem Kind zum Beispiel gesehen, dass der wahnsinnig doll auf technische Sachen abfährt. Und dass ein anderes Kind, was genau gleich alt ist und was neben ihm sieht, wird davon völlig kalt gelassen. Dieses Kind ist wahnsinnig schwer von seinem iPad zu trennen. Und wenn ich mir das überlege, ich kann mich so gut da reinversetzen, ich hätte als Kind dafür getötet für ein iPad.
Ja, für Gameboy haben wir getötet. Früher, als wir noch für Gameboys getötet haben.
Genau, das werden wir mal unseren Kindern erzählen. Wir mussten für unsere Gameboys noch töten. Und die waren schwarz-weiß gezogen.
Und die Batterien waren nach ein paar Stunden leer.
Ja, das bleibt ja vielleicht so.
Alex, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Gute Nacht.
Die Frage, was da schon alles angelegt ist, das finde ich schon sehr spannend. Vor allen Dingen, was müssen wir denn alles anlegen, damit das Ding anfängt, sich sein Ding zu bauen? Und ich glaube, dazu gehört zum Beispiel Motivation. Das für mich war faszinierend, dass das kleine Beast alles genau wusste, was es wollte. Es wusste oft nicht, dass es das wollte. Aber es gab, und es wusste auch noch nicht, was der Unterschied ist. Wenn sie so zur Welt kommen, dann ist ja dieses Ding, entweder alles ist okay, dann sabern sie wirklich vor sich hin und kichern und so und machen nichtliche Geräusche. Oder alles ist scheiße und dann schreien sie. Und es gibt nichts dazwischen. Es gibt nur totales Glück oder totales Leid. Und womit dieses Glück und Leid verknüpft, ist das Lernen die Erst. Und dafür gibt es eine Reihe von parallelen Mechanismen. Zum Beispiel dieses Leid ist Hunger, dieses Leid ist Schmerz, dieses Leid ist zu kalt, dieses Leid ist langweilig. Und später gibt es dann auch verschiedene Responses, um einzufordern, jetzt möchte ich bitte mehr Unterhaltung haben oder jetzt möchte ich bitte was zu essen haben. Und trotzdem ist aber sowas wie Hunger und Interesse nach Neuigkeiten sowas auch schon eingebaut.
Das ist nicht vielleicht eher ein Reiz? Für dich ist es ein Reiz, für ihn ist es ein Response.
Er gibt eine Response auf den Reiz. Das heißt, er kriegt das interne Signal, dass da ein Bedarf besteht im System, auf irgendeiner Ebene. Und dass das dringlich ist und das das Systeme das überschrubst. Es geht dir nach außen, genau.
Wie kriegen wir da jetzt die Kurve wieder? Die künstliche Intelligenz?
Ganz einfach, wir nehmen Matthias ran.
Hallo Matthias. Hallo. Tag. Du hattest auch eine Frage zur künstlichen Intelligenz.
Mich beschäftigt die Frage, die menschliche Intelligenz zeichnet ja aus diese Fähigkeit des Vergessenes. Wir sammeln ja nicht Unmengen Wissen an, das wir vorsichtig halten, sondern das Gehirn ist ja in der Lage auch auszusortieren. Und das müsste ja eine künstliche Intelligenz, wenn sie dann wirklich von uns als Intelligenz wahrgenommen werden sollte, ja eigentlich auch können.
Der Trick heißt einfach Filtern. Du machst ja vorher, nachher, und Dinge, die du nicht mehr brauchst, werden auch in so neuronalen Netzen, die man nachprogrammiert, werden ja Synapsen auch genauso verstärkt, wie im Gehirn, die öfter benutzt werden. Und wenn irgendwas mal nicht mehr benutzt wird, dann wird das auch abgebaut. Also das wird ja schon versucht zu modellieren.
Es scheint auch so zu sein, dass wir eigentlich gar nicht so viel vergessen. Das Problem ist, wir kommen nun nicht mehr ran. Das ist einfach wie so ein Netz, wo das immer mehr Zeug drüber geschrieben wird und neue Verbindungen gemacht werden. Und irgendwann sind das so viele Verbindungen, dass wir nur die stärksten Verbindungen folgen können und dass wir große Schwierigkeiten hätten, an diese kleinen Sachen ranzukommen. Und dann merkt man, früher bei Hirnoperationen durfte man auch so tolle Sachen machen, dass man am offenen Kopf, weil die Leute sind ja bei den Hirn-OPs bei Bewusstsein, so Elektroden reinpikst und so ein bisschen reizt. Und wenn ich selber mal eine Hirnoperation hätte, möchte ich das unbedingt machen, damit das irgendeinen Sinn hat. Und dabei erinnern die Leute plötzlich an Sachen, die sie vergessen haben von früher. Und das ist total faszinierend, weil plötzlich diese Verbindungen verfolgt werden können, an die man normalerweise nicht rankommt, durch den richtigen Kontext. Also ich glaube nicht, dass unser Gehirn so gut ist in Vergessen. Unser Gehirn ist einfach so schlecht in Erinnern.
Also wenn du nach der Sendung nochmal 10 Minuten Zeit hast, können wir uns draußen gerne hinsetzen.
Wir haben ja auch einen kleinen chirurgischen Betrieb eingebaut.
Kennst du das mit dem Niesreiz bei Look Around You?
Kennst du Look Around You?
Das Bild hab ich jetzt den ganzen Tag immer...
Wir machen mal Nachrichten, danach geht's intelligent weiter hier bei uns. Ey Samma, der Typ da hinten, ist das nicht der Typ von der Fritz Music Tour?
Quatsch, der hat doch gar keinen Bus dabei.
Nee, der daneben, der mit dem Bus, wo Fritz Music Tours draufsteht. Ja, das könnte sein.
Von Rammstein über Seed bis zu die Ärzte.
Von Sido über Bushido bis zu Materia und den Kalkbrenners. Und erlebt eine Tour durch das Berliner Musikgeschehen von damals bis hier und jetzt.
Fritz Music Tours Berlin.
Nur echt mit dem Typen mit dem Bus. Auf Wunsch auch als Walking-Tour. Dann nur echt mit dem Typen ohne Bus. Fritz Music Tours Berlin.
Mehr dazu bei Fritz im Netz.
Unter Events. Und das war's mal.
Hier ist Chaosradio 187 mit Erdgeist, Joscha und Holger.
Es geht um künstliche Intelligenz und wir sind immer noch bei den Maschinen, also bei den mechanischen Dingern stehen.
Was ich da gerade total spannend fand, als der Joscha erzählte mit dem mit der Nadel da rein und so Regionen wieder reaktivieren. Wie im Gehirn ist denn da dieses Wissen so überhaupt abgespeichert? Also gibt's da irgendwie so die eine Region für, hier ist gerade mein Kochwissen und hier ist, keine Ahnung, soziale, emotionale Intelligenz? Nee, das ist einfach irgendwo und wird irgendwo hin konstruiert, wenn man sich erinnert. Da piekt man dann einfach nur wild rum und guckt, ah, da kommt mit dem raus.
Es gibt so verschiedene Dinge. Das eine ist, auf der untersten Ebene wird das, wir haben im Cortex alle möglichen Konzepte abgelegt und die sind miteinander verdrahtet mit bestimmten Arten von Grundrelationen, glaube ich. Und die sind aber nicht die ganze Zeit aktiv. Und wenn die aktiviert werden, dann werden die erst wirksam sozusagen.
Du sagst, entschuldige, du sagst, glaubst du.
Das heißt, gibt es valide Forschung dazu? Es gibt ganz viele valide Forschung dazu. Okay, weil du sagst, das glaubst du.
Da dachte ich, das machen das Wissenschaftler erst mal eine Hypothese, bis es widerlegt.
Ja, nee, ich wollte nur wissen, ob das jetzt eine Floskel war oder ob es tatsächlich nicht wirklich klar ist, sondern ob da... Das ist alles so eine Sache. Wenn jemand zum Beispiel heute über die Verdauung redet, dann würde er vernünftigerweise als Wissenschaftler auch sagen, glaubst du. Weil so alle zehn Jahre wandelt sich unsere Vorstellung davon, wozu das Cholesterin nun genau gut ist und ob das gut oder schlecht für uns ist. So gesehen ist es redlich, dass du glaubst, du sagst das. Und trotzdem haben wir eine ungefähre Vorstellung, in welche Richtung wir gucken müssen. Das ist auch nicht alles unbekannt, aber manche Sachen sind zu konstruktive Erfordernisse und andere sind biologische Erfordernisse. Und manche Sachen wissen wir noch nicht so genau, es könnte so oder so sein. Die zurzeit dominante Theorie geht davon aus, dass wir die Neuronen im Cortex sich in sozusagen Grundschaltkreise verschalten. Das sind die Cortical Columns. Von denen gibt es ziemlich viele und jede von denen enthält ungefähr so 50.000 Neuronen, die untereinander wie so ein Schaltkreis verschaltet sind. Und die bedecken diesen Cortex in Regionen und diese Regionen unterscheiden sich in der Zusammensetzung der beteiligten Neurontypen. Das ist relativ subtil, aber doch so deutlich, dass man mit dem Mikroskop das Gehirn in lauter funktionale Areale einteilen kann. Das hat zuerst ein Mann namens Brotmann gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, ob er es zuerst gemacht hat, aber zumindest hat er das so deutlich zuerst publiziert, dass es nach ihm benannt wurde. Diese Brotmannschen Areale sind seitdem nur ganz wenig revidiert worden mit neuerer Forschung. Also das gibt ziemlich viel Ähnlichkeit mit dieser physischen Landkarte des Cortex und funktionalen Geschichten, die dabei stattfinden.
Aber da sind ja nicht explizite Erinnerungen drin gespeichert, wie in einer Schublade, wo ich reingucke, und sage, ah, meine Führerscheinprüfung.
Ne, was da gespeichert ist, sind natürlich immer Informationen. Und Informationen über Konzepte bestehen aus relationalen Zusammenhängen. Das bedeutet, es werden Zusammenhänge gespeichert, wie einzelne Dinge miteinander verknüpfen. Vielleicht, wie kann man sich das vorstellen? Nehmen wir mal an, unser Gedächtnis ist so eine Art Teppich. Und die Erinnerungen, die einzelnen Objekte, an die wir uns erinnern können, sind Knoten in diesem Teppich. Und die Elemente, aus denen diese Erinnerungen bestehen, sind wiederum Knoten in diesem Teppich. Zum Beispiel erinnere ich mich an ein Gesicht von einer Frau. Und darin gab es diese blühen Augen, die waren aus dem Telefonat. Und die sind als Konzepte unter diesem anderen Konzept angeordnet, haben eine bestimmte räumliche Relation zueinander. Und das Ganze ist eingebettet in andere Konzepte, zum Beispiel in so ein Frauenkonzept und Dispoco-Konzept und alle möglichen anderen durch bestimmte Fadentypen. Das sind die Fäden, aus denen dieser Teppich gewebt ist. Dieser Teppich, der kann sozusagen aktiviert werden, indem irgendwas daran zupft. Wenn da was dran zupft, an dem Teppich, dann heben wir eine Menge von Knoten auf einmal raus. Das ist dann ein Zusammenhang. Und die gleichen Knoten können aber in einem anderen Zusammenhang was anderes bedeuten, je nachdem, was sonst noch so aktiv ist, weil andere Fäden damit da sind und die Fäden in alle Richtungen ziehen.
Ist das dann vielleicht eine Transferleistung, wenn man diese anderen Knoten benutzt, um ein bestimmtes Problem aus einem anderen Bereich zu lösen? Teils, teils. Ist das Kreativität, Fantasie, kann man das versuchen, da durch spontane Schälverschaltungen?
Es gibt Modelle von Kreativität, die dadurch funktionieren, dass man das Rauschen erhöht. Dadurch gibt es Schälverschaltungen und dann wird wiederum auf der anderen Seite gefiltert. Man guckt, welche von diesen verrauschten Sachen kann ich so zusammensetzen, dass sie doch wieder Sinn ergeben.
Das Saufen ist doch zu was, Juk.
Tatsächlich säuft unser Gehirn ja sozusagen die ganze Zeit. Also wenn wir uns diese Neuronen angucken, die sind ja total übel. Also so ein Neuron, das ist so ein Haufen Gallard und der hat eine ganz schlechte Signal-to-Noise-Ratio. Also das heißt, aus dem Rauschen kommt ein bisschen Signal raus und die verstärken das gegenseitig und helfen sich gegenseitig, um da irgendwas vorzubringen. Und selbst wenn wir unseren Neurotransmittern massiv rumschrauben durch Alkohol und Drogen und so weiter und so fort, versucht das System immer noch, da irgendwas Sinnvolles rauszukriegen. Und das hat das erstaunlich gut. Stimmt.
Okay, ich versuch dir dann die Brücke zu schlagen, dass wenn wir irgendwie ungefähr raushaben, wie so Wissen im Gehirn abgelegt ist, ob das vielleicht auch eine Strategie wäre, so Wissen zugreifbar, dann Algorithmen irgendwo hinsortieren zu lassen, wo es dann auf ähnliche Art und Weise wieder abrufbar ist und wie man das da tut.
Dazu müssen wir natürlich erst mal erforschen, was das überhaupt für Mechanismen sind. Ich wollte gerade sagen, wäre das nicht eine viel zu komplexe Aufgabe für den Anfang?
Ich weiß es nicht. Irgendwie müssen wir ja Wissen in diesem Computer... Warum unterhalten wir uns eigentlich mit anderen? Weil ich dich so gerne berichtige. Aber trotzdem, wenn das zu komplex ist, wie es im Gehirn passiert, wie speichert man denn überhaupt Wissen? Wie macht da Watson, dieser Computer, der da einen Jet-Buddy gewonnen hat, wie macht der, dass er irgendwie auf das Wissen da zugreifen kann? Oder ist es dann auch nur gefaked, indem er dann die wahrscheinlichste, keine Ahnung, Webseite in oder die Wikipedia-Seite, in dem das eventuell drinstehen könnte, dann da irgendwie hochrankt? Also gibt es da eine Wissensaufbereitung gerade in den Systemen, die versuchen wissen, irgendwo Persistent zu speichern? Oder ist es immer noch alles nur verschlagwortet und dann schnell genug nachgeguckt, damit es aussieht wie eine schlaue Antwort?
Na ja, das Ding ist, dass da in den Watson sind ja im Grunde genommen nur Buchstaben drin. Also Symbole. Und diese Symbole, man könnte argumentieren, die bedeuten ja im Grunde genommen nichts. Da ist so ein Haken dran, ich glaube sowas Bedeutung gibt es auch eigentlich gar nicht. Im strengen Sinne. Was es nur gibt, ist eine Kodierung. Also eine Kodierung über die Reize, die die Welt uns gibt. Wir fassen die so und so zusammen, aber das heißt nicht, dass wir jemals wissen können, ob das wirklich so ist, was wir da sehen. Wir haben auch solche Experimente gemacht, dass wir zum Beispiel unsere Fußballspiel-Roboter, die normalerweise die Welt durch eine Kamera und Bewegungs-Sensoren wahrnehmen und Druck-Sensoren, die haben wir aus der wirklichen Welt rausgenommen und haben die in eine Simulation gesteckt. Und in dieser Simulation haben die eine simulierte Welt bekommen mit simulierten Kamerabildern. Und die hatten die gleichen Fehler wie die echten Kamerabilder, damit wir die gleichen Bildverarbeitungs-Algorithmen machen konnten. Und es gab für den Robot überhaupt keine Chance festzustellen, ob der in einer Simulation in der wirklichen Welt ist. Weil die Simulation produzierte die gleichen Muster. Die Welt ist für das System ein Mustergenerator. Und dieses Lernen aus den Mustern ist der Weg, wie Menschen unser Wissen bekommen über die Welt. Also die beiden Mädchen, die kleinen Töchter, von denen wir gehört haben, die hatten natürlich eine Struktur. Also die hatten Motivation und Interesse, die Welt zu erkunden. Und die wussten aber nicht, in was für einer Welt die geboren werden und ob es in der Hunde und Katzen gibt und Gummibärchen. Das mussten die erst rausfinden. Und das bedeutet, dass sozusagen dieser Teppich, von dem ich vorhin geredet hab, der ist auf der einen Seite festgebunden an der Welt. Und die Welt zupft an diesem Teppich und zieht den in eine bestimmte Form. Und dieses assoziative Lernen, also das Weben durchziehen, dass es einfach der Teppich in die richtige Form gezogen wird, ist nur einer von vielen Mechanismen. Manche Muster kriegt man damit nicht hin. Manchmal muss man häkeln. Und ich glaube, für dieses Häkeln brauchen wir unser Bewusstsein. Also die Prozesse, die wir auch verbalisieren können. Das heißt, wir stecken da so eine Handvoll Nadeln rein, unsere Aufmerksamkeit. Und dann greifen wir uns ein paar Knoten raus und bringen die in eine neue Ordnung. Also wir ordnen diese Fäden anders an. Und wir können da auch nicht auf einmal allzu viele Sachen hochheben, dann fallen die Fäden nämlich runter. Also technisch ausgedrückt, es wäre super schwer eine Mechanik zu bauen, die in so ein Teppich reingreift. Und ganz viele Nadeln hat. Und auf definierte Weise da drin neue Muster machen kann, wenn ich davon Hunderte von Nadeln habe. Das geht nur mit einer Hand voll. Sonst wird die Mechanik zu kompliziert. Und so ganz einfach ausgedrückt. Ich glaube, das ist der Grund, weshalb wir auf einmal nur so wenig Sachen in der Aufmerksamkeit behalten können. Also sie zu Hause an den Nicht-Bildschirmen können sich das ja mal vorstellen. Auf dem Fensterbrett, mental vorgestellt, stehen jetzt Blumentöpfe. Da steht am Anfang nur einer. Dann stellen sie einen zweiten dazu, einen dritten, einen vierten und einen fünften. Das machen sie so lange, bis sie die Übersicht verlieren und anfangen Blumentöpfe zusammenzufassen. Und bei mir hört das so ungefähr bei sechs, sieben Blumentöpfen auf. Vielleicht gibt es Leute, die neun schaffen. Aber ich glaube, wenn jemand schafft, 20 zu machen, dann ist der so ein Rainman, dann ist der so ein Idiot Savant, der in bestimmte andere Verschaltungen sehr im Gehirn hat und dafür anderes nicht kann. Und das heißt, wir können wirklich nur so eine handvoll Elemente auf einmal in unserer mentalen Aufmerksamkeit halten, dann müssen wir zusammenfassen. Und was die Intelligenztests messen, ist im Grunde genommen, wie viele Fäden kann ich gleichzeitig hochhalten, bevor mir ein Faden runterfällt. Das ist kein besonderer Tugend, einfach nur Puzzle lösen.
Ist das deine besondere Art oder Gabe, mit solchen Metaphern solche Dinge zu erklären?
Oder ist das tatsächlich die Art und Weise, wie ihr sowas auch diskutiert, wenn ihr da vor allen Dingen auch interdisziplinärer angeht? Damit halt jeder weiß, worüber gesprochen wird. Das Ding ist, dass es diese Disziplin eigentlich gar nicht gibt. Die KI hat ja angefangen als so was super interdisziplinäres. Wenn man sich das mal anschaut, die Leute, die da hingekommen sind, das ist total cool. Da sind der Mac Carsey, der hatte sich so beschäftigt, was Berechnen überhaupt ist. Und in seinem Umfeld wurde dann die Programmiersprache Lisp erfunden. Der Nathaniel Rochester, der hat den ersten Assembler geschrieben. Also das erste Programm, mit dem man Maschinensprache programmieren konnte. Minsky, der ziemlich berühmt ist. Der Shannon, den wir vorhin schon erwähnt haben, der herausgekriegt hat, was Information ist oder zumindest eine wesentliche Interpretation davon. Die Informationstheorie. Denn der Selfridge, der maschinelle Wahrnehmung später gemacht hat. Der Ray Solomonoff, das war so ein... Jemand, der hat sich mit Informationskomplexität beschäftigt und hat sich dann mit statistischem und maschinen Lernen beschäftigt. Newell und Simon, die kamen eher aus der Psychologie. Lauter so Leute aus ganz vielen Feldern. Und die sind zusammengekommen und haben gesagt, lasst uns doch das mal bauen, das muss doch jetzt gehen, dass man diese neue Technik der Computer benutzt, um damit Denken nachzubilden. Und innerhalb von so einer Generation ist das pervertiert. Da hat sich das Ganze, so ein großer Bruch war glaube ich, in den 70ern, als der KI-Winter anfing, die KI vor allen Dingen auf Anwendungen konzentriert. Das heißt, wir haben dann angefangen, uns so auf logische Beweissysteme zu konstruieren und formale Sprachen und maschinelles Lernen und Dinge, die man nutzbringend einsetzen konnte. Das war immer total hilfreich und es war auch viel bescheidener und man hatte auch den Vorteil, dass man in das Grand Proposal Sachen reinschreiben konnte, die man zwei, drei Jahre später auch abliefern konnte. Das ist total gut, um das nächste Funding zu kriegen. Wenn man aber stattdessen sagt, meine Wissenschaft ist eigentlich eher philosophisch und ich mache diese Philosophie, weil ich als Programmierer ja weiß, dass ich nichts Komplexes mir ausdenken kann, ohne Fehler zu machen. Das lernt man so im ersten Semester. Ich weiß nicht mal, wie sortieren geht, bis ich es programmiert habe, weil alle Bugs, möglichen Bugs drin sind. Wie kann ich eine Theorie vom Denken mir als Philosophengrün den Lehnstuhl ausdenken, ohne dass ich das programmiere? Um Gottes Willen. Also muss ich es programmieren, aber das wird nicht morgen fertig sein. Das wird vielleicht in 50 Jahren fertig sein, vielleicht in 100 Jahren. Wir wissen nicht, in was für Flügigkeiten wir da noch reinrennen. Dafür kriegt man kein Funding. Und das führt dazu, dass...
Ach so, das ist ein Fusionsreaktor.
Außer es hört uns gerade durch Zufall irgendwie da draußen jemand mit. Wir bräuchten noch Geld.
Ich hab nun ein Konto in der Schweiz. Nein, bei mir.
Wir geben nachher die Kontonummer durch. Ne, übrigens braucht man auch inzwischen, wenn man überhaupt anfangen will, sich damit zu beschäftigen, gar nicht mehr so viel Funding, weil das Tolle ist, Computer kosten fast nichts mehr. So ein Computer kann unendlich viel mehr als ein Auto und der kostet so unendlich viel weniger. Das ist Wahnsinn, echt. Das ist der Hammer. Ich begeister mich immer wieder, wie wenig man einen Computer kriegt. Dann sagt jemand, da hast du diesen scheiß teuren Mac mit dem ganzen Speicher. Das kostet doch 200 Euro mehr. Dafür kriegst du bei deinem Auto nicht mal einen anders lackierten Rückspiegel. Mann, das ist der Hammer.
Andererseits kannst du einfach auch schon mit einem Rechner von vor zehn Jahren kannst du da schon alles mitmachen. Den kriegst du geschenkt heutzutage, weil hier kostet mehr Strom als der Rechner an sich.
Genau, also Computer sind wirklich echt kein Ding.
Du hast gerade gesagt, du brauchst kein Funding.
Du bist ja rüber im Clan. Nee, ich muss natürlich was essen. Ich muss meine Familie füttern. So Kleinigkeiten. Aber Computer sind nicht das Problem. Und natürlich, für manche Sachen wird man einen Großrechner brauchen. Aber unsere Schwierigkeiten, die wir in der KI haben, die sind im Allgemeinen nicht, weil unser Rechner nicht groß genug ist. Und durch die Amazon Cloud und Google und so weiter können wir inzwischen auch Sachen machen mit Rechnaufwand, die unglaublich sind. Da gab es zum Beispiel so im letzten Jahr eine Geschichte, die ist durchs Internet gegangen, weil Katzenbilder drin vorkamen. Und zwar haben ein paar Forscher von Google zusammen mit Forschern von Stanford, wir sind da in sehr großer räumlicher Nachbarschaft, deswegen geht das gut, ein System trainiert, YouTube-Videos anzugucken. Die haben nicht die ganzen Videos genommen, sondern die haben einfach zufällig Bilder aus YouTube ausgewählt. Also einfach mitten aus dem Clip rein, random, ohne sortieren. Zack, einfach so Frames rausgecuttet, 30 Millionen Stück. Und haben die in einen Supercomputer reingefüttert mit einem neuronalen Netz. Und das neuronalen Netz, das wusste am Anfang gar nichts. Das war nur als so eine Hierarchie verschaltet, so mit 15 Layern. Dann haben die das da drei Tage trainiert.
Warte, was heißt neuronales Netz?
Neuronales Netz ist so eine krude mathematische Abstraktion von dem, was Nerven tun. Man kann das verwenden, um zum Beispiel Sensormotorkopplung zu lernen oder Assoziativ zu lernen. Und dieses Ding hat durch ein bestimmtes assoziatives Lernverfahren. Du sagtest gerade, das wusste von nichts. Aber es hatte irgendwelche Prozeduren, die es doch schon gekannt haben oder implementiert haben, nach denen es lernt. Es hat versucht, darin Ordnung zu finden. Aber nicht nach irgendwelchen raffinierten Verhältnissen, sondern vor allen Dingen ein bisschen örtliche Nähe, zum Beispiel als Anfangskriterium. Und nach diesen drei Tagen hat das Ding mit einer ziemlich großen Sicherheit Katzenbilder erkennen können, unter anderem. Niemand hat ihm gesagt, es kommen Katzen in den Videos, wo er achte, besonders auf Katzen. Sondern es gab einfach nur genügend YouTube-Videos, wenn man ihm später ein Katzenvideo gezeigt hat, eine charakteristische Antwort kam. Also es hat sozusagen eine Art Großmutterneuron ausgebildet, für Katzen. Also ein spezielles Konzept hat sich von selbst daraus destilliert. Ohne, dass es wusste, dass es Katze ist. Also es konnte mit Katze nichts anfangen. Es ist auch viel ärmer als Menschen. Das coole ist, wenn man dieses Computerprogramm jetzt nehme, das er jetzt fertig trainiert, und ich würde dem YouTube-Videos zeigen, und es kommt eine Katze drin vor, dann leuchtet dann eine spezielle Lampe auf sozusagen. Ich könnte einfach sagen, hier ist jetzt die Katzenlampe und die leuchtet immer auf, wenn eine Katze kommt, egal wie die beleuchtet ist und in welcher Stelle im Bild. Das ist jetzt nicht hundert Prozent zuverlässig. Und das Ding weiß auch nicht wirklich was über Katzen, hat nie eine gestreichelt und so. Aber das coole ist, nur durch angucken von Frames, ohne Bedeutung, findet das das. Es hat nicht nur Katzen gefunden, sondern auch menschliche Umrisse und Fahrräder und alle möglichen anderen Gegenstände, die so vorkommen. Also ungefähr so 20.000 Objektkategorien haben sie getestet und davon hat es dann so 12 Prozent erkannt. Immerhin. Aber wenn man sich das überlegt, wie viele Daten das sind, ich habe mir überlegt, wie viel sieht denn mein Baby im halben Jahr? So im ersten halben Jahr, danach kann es vielleicht ungefähr genauso viel.
Das Auge ist ja auch vorher noch ein vorgeschalteter Computer, der auch für das Gehirn schon ziemlich viel vom Dekodieren der Gegend macht. Da kann ja schon ziemlich viel Physik, findet er im Auge statt, schon mal vorberechnen, wo Objekte demnächst sein würden, damit wird das Gehirn gar nicht behelligt. Also das ist irgendwie schon so ein vorgelagertes Teil des Gehirns eigentlich. Sodass dann selbst was noch an vielen Frames dort bei dem Auge ankommt, diese 25 Frames pro Sekunde, die werden dann schon noch runtergerechnet, dort irgendwie die wichtigsten Informationen rausgeholt und dann erst dem Gehirn zur Weiterverarbeitung gegeben.
Wie viele Frames kommen deinem Gehirn an?
Das kommen halt... Kann man so nicht sagen. Das wird halt schon vorher aufgearbeitet und sind dann keine Einzelframes mehr. Weil du ja irgendwie nicht so siehst. Also du glaubst denn nur, du würdest das ganze Bild erkennbar, dein Gehirn muss wieder zusammensetzt, aber du guckst ja immer einzeln und dann siehst du aus dem Augenwiegel schon, dass bestimmte Strukturen ist, wie da sitzt Holgi und dann gucke ich woanders hin, sehe immer noch, da müsste jetzt Holgi sitzen, wenn ich wieder zurück gucke und da sitzt kein Holgi mehr, dann bin ich erschrocken.
Was sollst du uns mal kurz überlegen? Also angenommen, wir können jetzt nicht genau rechnen und ich will jetzt auch nicht seriös sein, um ein Bild anzugucken, braucht man eigentlich mehrere Sekunden, wenn man vor null guckt, bis das Bild ankommt, weil wir setzen das jetzt so einmal ehrlich zusammen. Aber angenommen, wir hätten ein super schlaues Turbo-Baby, das ein Bild pro Sekunde schafft. Und das Baby ist sieben Stunden wach und macht die ganze Zeit nichts anderes, als auf Bilder zu starren. Das ist natürlich nicht gut.
Aber wenn es 30 Millionen Sekunden hat, das ja.
Dann würde es für diese 3600 mal sieben Stunden, für diese 30 Millionen Bilder, ich glaube über 1000 Tage brauchen. Ist das richtig? Ich glaube ja. Das heißt, unser System hat mehrere Größenordnungen, mehr Daten gekriegt, als ein Mensch verarbeiten könnte. Im halben Jahr, nachdem der Mensch wahrscheinlich besser klassifiziert als das System. Es finde ich aber trotzdem erstaunlich, dass das System das rausgekriegt hat, weil der Mensch, der kann ja gezielt lernen. Das Baby kann z.B. näher an die Katze rankrabbeln und kann Experimente mit ihr machen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Katze anfassen.
Du hast halt viel mehr Wege. Ich kann den Kopf bewegen und gucken, trennt sich die vom Hintergrund, wenn ich den Kopf bewege, ist die da weiter am Vordergrund und so was alles. Das heißt, das Baby braucht auch höchstwahrscheinlich gar nicht so lange, um Katze zu erkennen. Also um den Unterschied Katze zu erkennen. Ja, natürlich. Das sind halt viel bessere Daten. Und es kann gezielt bei den Stellen, wo es Unsicherheiten hat, Experimente machen, also gezielt explorieren. Aber das Ding ist, das ungezielte Expirieren, rein statistisch, kostet nichts mehr. Weil das ganze Internet liegt ja irgendwo bei Google rum. Und wenn wir wollen, können wir also mit Google reden und können sagen, lass uns doch mal zusammen ein paar Forschungssachen machen. Oder ich kann zu Google gehen oder so, wenn die mich nehmen wollen und mich KI machen lassen wollen. Und dann können wir da diese Daten durchforsten und nach Regelmäßigkeiten suchen. Und da die Computer so ziemlich schnell sind inzwischen, ist das ja kein Problem. Die werden ohne Ermüdung diese Daten durchmustern und möglicherweise ähnliche Codierungen über diese Daten finden, wie wir finden, wenn wir durch die Welt gehen. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, dass natürlich es viel spannender ist, ein System zu bauen, das so wie wir durch die Welt geht und es dann viel weniger Daten braucht. Weil ich möchte ja auch verstehen, wie wir funktionieren.
Und vor allen Dingen würde das System, was du dann bei Google laufen lässt, nichts aus den Unterschieden machen, die es festgestellt hat, oder?
Ja, Google würde dann bestimmt was draus machen.
Ich weiß doch, was sie filtern werden. Vielleicht gibt es noch einen Betalecount, wo du deine Katzenbilder sehen darfst, nur noch für Geld oder so.
Wir haben es jetzt noch nicht geschafft, Google Geld zu geben. Ich hab seit mindestens zehn Jahren darauf gewartet, dass ich Google Geld zahlen darf.
Ich kaufe dir doch ein Nexus.
Das geht aber auch nicht direkt zu Google, das Geld. Ich glaube, Google bezahlt ja die Hardware-Firmen dafür, dass das Google Zeug draufkommt.
Das ist ein Google Wallet-Account.
Du könntest... Du könntest doch...
Also ich würde für Gmail gutes Geld bezahlen. Achso, ich dachte, sonst hätten wir das irgendwie anders machen können.
Du schaltest Werbung in deinem Sinne, dann kommt Google Geld an.
Egal.
Was die Maschine, die du dann bei Google da schreiben würdest, oder was der Computer da bei Google machen würde, würde halt einen Unterschied feststellen. Der Unterschied wäre möglicherweise Katze, aber das würde sich nicht in irgendwie ein Verhalten oder eine Handlung oder einen Ethos übersetzen. Das müsstest du aber reinschreiben.
Ja, das widerspricht sich aber nicht. Vielleicht können wir ja zusätzlich ähnliche Lernverfahren dafür anwenden. Aber es ist auch klar, das ist nur ein reines visuelles Paradigma, was keine Bewegungen kann und das ist nicht verknüpft mit irgendwelchen Handlungs- oder sozialen Zusammenhängen und so fort, sondern nur ein ganz primitives Modell von einem winzigen Teil des Gehirns.
Kann man einem Computer beibringen, dass er jetzt mal gefälligst forschen geht? Also du bekommst das Bild und sag mal, was du jetzt damit machen würdest. Dann muss der Computer dann irgendwie einen Antrieb haben, um das rausfinden zu wollen, aber das kann man ihm ja irgendwie kodifizieren als ein seiner Antriebe und Forscherdrang. Und dann braucht er eigentlich nur noch die Möglichkeit, da wie, ja, zu interagieren.
Ich hab eine ganze Weile überlegt, wie könnte man denn Forscherdrang einbauen? Und die beste Idee, die ich bis jetzt dazu gefunden hab, die ist von Dietrich Dörner, so einem theoretischen Psychologen in Bamberg, dem einzigen Einhaber eines Lehrschluss für theoretische Psychologie, soweit ich informiert bin. Der ist allerdings inzwischen immer irritiert. Und der hat in der Zeit des Behaviourismus publiziert, was dazu führte, dass die meisten mit seinem Zeug nichts anfangen konnten. Und er hat dann aufgegeben, für die Psychologen zu schreiben und hat dann so geschrieben, dass normale Leute das verstehen, aber die Psychologen nicht mehr. Und, äh, meine Dissertation hat zum großen Teil davon gehandelt, das wieder in Wissenschaft zu übersetzen. Also es ist nicht unwissenschaftlich, was er da macht, es verwendet man einfach nicht die Sprache von den neuen Wissenschaften, also Cognitive Science und Cognitive Modellierung, Cognitive Architekturen, KI-Architekturen, die es eigentlich hätte übersetzt werden müssen, damit die Leute damit anfangen können. Ja, ich finde das total klasse. Der hat sich gesagt, irgendwann ist doch scheiß egal, was die Leute gerade für Zeug machen. Das meiste davon, was die Leute jetzt machen, da wird in 50 Jahren keine Sauberin nachgrähen. Lass uns lieber irgendwas machen, mit dem ich in 100 Jahren total berühmt werde.
Das ist eigentlich ein sehr guter Ansatz. Das hätte uns mal früher einfallen sollen.
Es nützt uns aber nichts. Wir müssen jetzt Brötchen kaufen.
Deswegen wollten wir ja dann nachher die Telefonnummer noch mal rausgeben, wo die Fanda...
Die Klare mit den kognitiven Trieben. Ich habe es schon erwähnt, dass ich glaube, dass neben den physiologischen Trieben, also sowas wie Hunger und Durst, und ich glaube Hunger und Durst erschlägt es nicht. Das sind Hunderte, die da Untertriebe aus dem Hunger und Durst bestehen, allein. Und Wärme und Kälte und Schmerzvermeidung und all diese Dinge. Dann gibt es Soziale. Dazu gehört es zum Beispiel, dass man von anderen Akzeptanzsignale bekommt und dass man auch von sich selber Akzeptanzsignale bekommt. Das ist auch wichtig, dass man sich auch dann korrekt sozial verhelfen, wenn keiner zuguckt. Das ist nicht dasselbe Verhalten wie das, was man der Öffentlichkeit zeigt. Aber trotzdem gibt es Dinge, die ich nicht tun würde, weil ich mir sonst nicht mehr in die Augen gucken könnte.
Das ist, wenn du nachts bei der roten Ampel stehen bleibst, wenn keiner da ist?
Es gibt Leute, die machen das. Ich mach das nicht, aber Leute, das habe ich gehört, das soll es geben. Aber da gibt es halt auch interessante Persönlichkeitstypen, die sich da unterscheiden an genau dieser Stelle, ob sie über die Straße gehen, wenn keiner zuguckt. Das Katastrophalste an dieser Sendung ist eigentlich, dass sie genau jetzt zu Ende ist. Ich wollte gerade das Rätsel lösen, wie KI geht. Okay, nächstes Mal. Das war Chaosradio 187, es gibt künstliche Intelligenz.
Ich habe den dringenden Verdacht, dass es noch ein Chaosradio zum Thema künstliche Intelligenz geben wird. Ich habe außerdem den Verdacht, dass es noch ein Chaosradio zum Thema künstliche Intelligenz geben wird.
Ich habe den Verdacht, wir sind gerade in der Schleife gelandet. Vielen Dank, Erdreiß, vielen Dank, Joscha.
Danke Holgi.
Es war schön hier.
Ja, dann kommen doch gefälligst einfach mal wieder. Das war das Chaosradio für diesen Monat.
Das nächste Chaosradio gibt es am letzten Donnerstag im März.